Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Chaos Radio 94, wir wollen eben die Musik hören und melden uns wieder.
Wir sortieren uns.
Wo war ich eben?
Du hast zu 94 gekommen und wir haben auch noch die Zeit den Raum anzusagen, worum es geht. Es geht nämlich heute um, darf ich?
Telefon, bitte.
Ja, es geht um Computer, Telefonie bzw. generell Telefonie und Computer, also die Themen, wo Computer und Telefonie zusammenkommen, das ist im einlichen Sinne nichts Neues, sondern das gibt es schon eine ganze Weile, aber es ist eben derzeit doch endlich mal ein heißes Thema, auch wenn man schon vor 10 Jahren geglaubt hat, das wäre schon ein heißes Thema, aber jetzt nähern wir uns dem auch langsam. Darüber wollen wir heute was erzählen.
Chaosradio 94, telefonieren mit Computern unser Thema heute im Blumenau Fritz, am Studio der Harald.
Guten Abend.
Guten Abend, ja.
Der Lars.
Guten Abend.
Und der Tim.
Und der Tim, der ist auch dabei.
Guten Abend. Bevor wir zum eigentlichen Thema kommen, wollten wir ein bisschen feichsen an dieser Stelle. Was las ich kürzlich in der Presse? Was ist denn da mit der Telekom wieder los? Also jetzt abgesehen von den üblichen Sachen.
Ja, es gab am Wochenende eine Pressemitteilung des Chaos Computer Club gepaart mit einer Veröffentlichung in der Datenschleuder. Das ist unsere Hauszeitschrift, die mehr oder weniger regelmäßig erscheint. Und dort wurde im Prinzip dokumentiert, dass es eigentlich eine ganze Reihe von gravierenden Sicherheitslöchern gibt in diesem T-Mart-Vertragssystem der Telekom, der T-Com. So genau zuordnen kann man das ja immer noch nicht. Das ist ein großes System, wo die Leute im Prinzip von zu Hause ihre eigenen Online-Accounts managen können, wo sie ihre Passwörter ändern können, wo sie ihre Web-Server konfigurieren können, online Backups durchführen können. Es gibt da so zahlreiche Dienste, die man da eben einrichten kann. Und das Besondere daran ist, dass man das eben auch nicht nur alleine machen kann, sondern man kann das eben auch für seinen Kollegen machen, weil das Ding so offen ist, dass man im Prinzip an jeden Vertrag rankommt.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einfach jetzt mal die Vertragsdaten des Bundesnachrichtendienst oder der türkischen Botschaft in Berlin ändern will, dann kann ich das eben ganz leicht tun, weil die Telekom sich da gedacht hat, wir machen das besonders leicht und wir müssen das nicht sicher machen.
Also man kann es jetzt nicht mehr tun.
Der Bundesnachrichtendienst ist bei der Telekom? Ich würde eigentlich erwarten, dass sie irgendwas eigenes haben.
Man wundert sich und man wundert sich, aber offensichtlich ist es so. Das hat sogar die Tagesschau, die sich selbst eklickt, als sie das irgendwie mal überprüfen wollten, was denn da sozusagen der CCC mal wieder alles so behauptet und es war auch für sie problemlos möglich, da mal eben Einblick zu erhalten. Mittlerweile geht es natürlich nicht mehr, weil die Telekom mittlerweile das gesamte System, dieses Opsock, schöner Name, das ist jetzt ein bisschen obzockt. Und ja, insofern gibt es halt gerade mal keine Möglichkeit für die Kunden da irgendwas zu ändern.
Die haben das nicht repariert, die haben es einfach ausgeschaltet.
Da konnte man auch nichts mehr anderes tun, als es auszuschalten und eigentlich können sie jetzt auch nichts mehr anderes tun, als es zu löschen und neu zu schreiben. Das war einfach so, Hanebüchen, also möglicherweise, wenn es so Berichte von Sicherheitslöchern gibt, dann ist das irgendwas ausgefuchstes, sowas wie ja, und der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus hat unter einer bestimmten Race-Condition und dieses und jenes passiert und wenn das Wetter mindestens 23 Grad hat bei der Luftfeuchtigkeit, dann kann man rein theoretisch und so, das sind eigentlich die typischen Sicherheitsprobleme, die man so findet bei Webseiten. Bloß hier war es einfach so, man geht so in seinen eigenen Vertrag, das kann jetzt auch echt jeder nachvollziehen, man hat dann so oben ja diese URL, die Adresse dieser Seite und klickt da so ein bisschen drinnen herum und der Dirk Heringhaus, der das herausgefunden hat, der hat dann halt einfach oben gesehen, dass in dieser URL unter anderem die Vertragsnummer drin statt, also seine Vertragsnummer, was ja zunächst einmal nichts besonderes ist. Dann hat er einfach mal so aus Spaß die Nummer geändert und hat sich dann sehr gewundert, dass eben schwuppdiwupp irgendein anderer Vertrag da war. Also für den er ja sozusagen überhaupt keine Zugriffsrechte besteht. Also die ganze Sicherheit des Systems bestand einfach nur dadrin, dass sie keine direkten Links auf den Rest geboten haben, aber man konnte sich halt diese Links einfach selber ausdenken und in zahlreichen Varianten. Jetzt ist nicht so, dass er gleich das an die große Glocke gehängt hat, sondern hat sich ja irgendwie mit der Telekom dann auseinandergesetzt und den irgendwie auch Mails geschrieben und gesagt, hier, ihr habt ein Sicherheitsloch.
Vor allem, er hat das bereits seit dem 30.05.2003, also seit über einem Jahr getan.
Und da gab es dann auch so, naja, also vereinzelt gab es dann auch so Maßnahmen, die ergriffen wurden, womit sie dann eben das eine konkrete Sicherheitsloch dann wieder abgedichtet haben durch, ja, nicht weiter wichtige Maßnahmen. Es waren dann halt immer noch so 100 andere offene Türen, weil einfach dieses Prinzip mit ich kann meine URL ändern und kann auf irgendwas zugreifen, das war so durchgehend durch das gesamte System möglich, dass es ihm dann nach einiger weiterer Datenakrobatik gelungen ist, auch die Server selbst, auf denen das System läuft, vollständig den gesamten Inhalt aller angeschlossenen Festplatten auch über das Web herunterzuziehen und so weiter und so weiter. Wenn man sich das durchliest, rollen sich einem die Fußnägel. Es ist so Hanebüchen, man mag es einfach nicht glauben, aber es ist halt wahr. Es ist einfach alles unten. Jetzt müssen sie sich was einfallen lassen.
Also der der der der T-Hack.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich einen Tusch an die Nacht.
Können wir auch gleich sagen, es gibt eine Dokumentation, dessen unter www.cccde sind alle Links zu finden. Der Wesentliche ist www.cccde.de. Dort ist das ausführlich dokumentiert, einschließlich des gesamten Verkehrs, des Kommunikationsverkehrs zwischen dem Dirk und der Telekom. Das ist auch alles sehr lesenswert. Dort zu sehen, wie wenig die denn auch einfach ernst genommen haben.
Was ich nicht verstehe, da sind dann sämtliche Vertragsdaten einsehbar, also ich kann deine Vertragsdaten sehen und so weiter und so fort.
Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Bundesnachrichtendienst. Hey, wissen die was? Wir gehen zur deutschen Telekom, die machen das schon. Da arbeiten ja auch Leute, also glaube ich jetzt so, da arbeiten Leute, die verstehen was davon, so Sicherheits-Experten.
Ja, das würde man eigentlich glauben wollen, weil die Telekom ist ja auch Mitglied in allen möglichen Initiativen für mehr Sicherheit im Netzwerk. Aber wenn man sich irgendwie also das anschaut, wie sie da rangegangen sind, dann ist das so, naja, so My First Web Application, was man so im PHP-Kurs dann irgendwie mal so als erstes hinhaut. Und dann guckt einem der Lehrer über die Schulter und sagt, naja, das funktioniert jetzt zwar ein bisschen, aber guck mal, du musst ja auch mal über Sicherheit irgendwie dir ein paar Gedanken machen. Dann sagt man so, aha, und am nächsten Tag hat man halt seine zweite Stunde. So, aber über diesen Punkt scheinen sie ganz offensichtlich nicht wirklich hinausgekommen zu sein. Das sind solche fahrlässigen Fehler, wie zum Beispiel die Passwörter werden auch nicht verschlüsselt abgespeichert.
Ja, also üblicherweise ist es eben in der ganzen IT-Industrie üblich, dass man Passwörter nie im Klartext speichert, sondern das Passwort dann immer nur mit irgendeinem sogenannten Hashtag abgelegt wird. Also da wird eine Prüfsumme über das Passwort abgelegt. Und aus dieser Prüfsumme kann ich das Passwort nicht wieder zurückrechnen, sondern ich kann nur mit der Prüfsumme und dem vom Anwender angegebenen Passwort feststellen, ob das richtig war, aber ich kann das nie wieder zurückwandeln. Und das hat man da eben schon falsch gemacht. Dazu kommt dann noch, dass also in diesem System dann wieder Passwörter für andere Zugänge von Rechnern in dem Telekom internen Netz drin waren. Und dass dann man festgestellt hat, dass in zahlreichen Fällen die Mitarbeiter der Telekom tatsächlich ihren Anmeldennamen als Passwort auch hatten. Also man konnte damit so mit Schmidt01 und Passwort Schmidt01...
Ja, aber auch Telekom1 und Passwort Telekom1 hat also auch schon dann auch mehr Rechte gehabt, weil man dann sozusagen dann auch mehr Akten in Rechten hat und so.
Das darf doch nicht wahr sein, die haben ja Millionen von Kunden, die können doch nicht...
Ja, aber es ist sogar noch schlimmer. Dann haben sie auch noch diese klassischen Fehler gemacht, dass man so oben die Pfade ändern kann. Man kennt das ja so unter Unix, nicht? Man kann halt in Pfade hineingehen, aber man kann mit Punkt Punkt auch wieder die Pfade zurückmarschieren. Das ging natürlich auch alles, sodass man auch den vollständigen Zugriff auf alle Festplatten, aller Server, auf denen dieses System lief, macht. Aber als ob das noch nicht genug wäre, kann ich eine Kopie von den BND-Sachen haben? Also wie in der Pressemitteilung des CCC so griffig formuliert wurde, können sich die Anwender dieses Systems sicher sein, dass die Daten zumindest beim CCC sicher sind.
Ja, bei der, wo sonst?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Auch das ist ja jetzt alles schon erschreckend genug. Es ging dann aber noch weiter und das zeigt dann eben auch eine ganze Menge darüber, wie die ganzen Prozeduren auch einfach keinerlei Sicherheitskonzept erkennen lassen. Also nicht nur, dass diese Anwendung fehlerhaft war, nein. Sie haben dann einfach den guten Rat abgelehnt, sie haben das einfach nicht ernst genommen. Aber es ging dann so weit, dass der Dirk hat dann angefangen, also er hat einfach so viel entdeckt, dass er das Unmögliche einfach mal auch noch überprüft hat. Das ging dann so weit, dass er die Nachnamen der Mitarbeiter genommen hat, geguckt hat, ob es Domains gibt, die auf diesen Namen enden, hat er gefunden. Dann waren dann Web-Server eingerichtet und auf diesen Web-Servern hat er dann unverschlüsselt einfach komplette Back-ups dieses Systems gefunden, auch wiederum mit Passwort, dann natürlich auch unverschlüsselt und so weiter und so weiter. Es ist einfach eine endlose Geschichte und es ist eine große, große Peinlichkeit. Der...
T-Hack?
Der...
T-Hack. Ja Chaos Radio 94 ist hier. Eigentlich wollten wir über telefonieren mit Computern, das werden wir auch im Laufe der Sendung noch machen. Wir werden euch auch auffordern, hier anzurufen, wie so üblich im Blumuna Fritz 0331 77 91 70. Im Moment unterhalten wir uns aber über den Teehawk. Und ich glaube, wir hatten noch was vergessen im puncto Teehawk.
Willst du noch einen Tusch, Harald? Nein, danke, das reicht durchaus. Man hat dann wohl offensichtlich ja auch noch unter anderem die Kundennummer der Deutschen Bundesbank gefunden, hat die Zugangsdaten der Bundesgrenzschutzdirektion Koblenz ausfindig machen können in diesen Datenbanken. Also es ist schon ein ganz unglaubliches Chaos.
Könntest du das nochmal sagen? Also was hat man gefunden?
Man hat gefunden die Zugangsdaten des BND, das hatten wir schon, der Bundesgrenzschutzdirektion Koblenz und zumindest die Kundennummer der Deutschen Bundesbank.
Ja, es ist wirklich unglaublich, was sich alles finden lässt beim Thema!
Ja, jetzt haben wir es aber auch ausgekostet.
Hat aber auch irgendwie gut getan.
Also das, was wichtig ist, ist, dass es eben hier nicht nur um eine kleine Sicherheitslücke geht, sondern dass das ganz konzeptionell sich durch alles durchzieht. Das geht von der Netzwerksicherheit dadurch, dass man die Standard-Windows-Laufwerksfreigaben nicht gelöscht hat, also das ist C-Dollar, was jeder, jedes Script-Kit, die ihr eben kennt, dass man diese ganzen Dinge einfach nicht gemacht hat. Also es geht nicht nur um diese Web-Applikation, sondern es geht eigentlich, das zieht sich durch das ganze Konzept durch und das ist also schon äußerst peinlich für so ein großes Unternehmen.
Ja und vor allem, man kann ja nicht müde werden darauf hinzuweisen, dass Sicherheit kein Zustand, sondern ein Prozess ist. Das heißt, man muss einfach auch in seinem System, unabhängig von der Software oder sonst irgendwelchen Zuständen, auch einfach dafür Sorge tragen, dass wenn mal irgendeine Schwäche erkannt wird, dass es eben so schnell wie möglich A, natürlich in, was dagegen getan wird. Das ist hier ganz offensichtlich überhaupt nicht, also fast nicht erfolgt.
Von wann war das? Mai 2003?
Ja, so da ging das halt los. Und vor allem, was eigentlich das Frechste ist, dass bis zum heutigen Tage einfach auch niemand davon in Kenntnis gesetzt wurde. Weil es bestanden ja diese Probleme schon vor einem Jahr. Und es wurde halt einfach auch niemandem gesagt, dass das überhaupt stattgefunden hat. Weil zu dem Zeitpunkt waren ja im Prinzip schon alle Passwörter auslesbar.
Das heißt, die Daten des Bundesnachrichtendienstes waren auslesbar, möglicherweise sogar ausgelesen von irgendjemandem anders, der einfach nur nicht drüber geredet hat.
500.000 Leute können einfach mal ihre Passwörter wegschmeißen.
Und niemand...
Man weiß auch gar nicht, was so geändert ist. Man weiß auch nicht, was runtergeladen ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob die da irgendwelche aussagenkräftigen Lockfalls haben.
Da gab es ja auch so Funktionen für Remote Backup, wo Kunden im Prinzip ihre Backups bei der Telekom hinterliegen konnten und die waren dann eben auch ausgespart.
Secure Backup, damit ihre Daten sicher sind.
Toll, oder?
Also man kann eigentlich nur noch mit dem Kopf schütteln. Also wenn es nicht so lustig wäre, wäre es eigentlich echt traurig. Und es ist eigentlich sehr verwunderlich, dass im Jahre 2004 sowas noch möglich ist. Weil das ist einfach, diese Telekom ist ja... Ja, also das ist, man kann nur noch mit dem Kopf schütteln. Aber es zeigt auch einfach, dass große Unternehmen einfach nicht funktionieren. Gerade, also wenn jemand der Meinung ist, er wäre jetzt bei einem Großunternehmen sicherer, weil die hätten ja die Ressourcen, wie du schon so schön angefangen hast. Man würde ja meinen, ja. Man würde vielleicht meinen, aber es ist einfach nicht so. Da weiß einfach nicht, was die eine Hand, nicht was die andere tut. Und man ist einfach bei einer kleinen, dedizierten Bude, die irgendwie auch nach außen ein ganz anderes Maß an Transparenz darlegt, die auch eine ganz andere Kommunikation mit ihren Kunden führt und die auch sofort sagt, wenn irgendwas daneben gegangen ist. Das ist ja auch ein Grad an Ehrlichkeit, die man erwarten würde. Ich meine, was hilft es mir, wenn die das beheben, aber ich weiß noch nicht mal, dass das überhaupt so war.
Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass der Bundesnachrichtendienst von all dem nichts weiß, solange er nicht die Datenschleuder liest.
Naja, jetzt wissen sie wahrscheinlich davon. Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Ich meine, die lesen natürlich die Datenschleuder. Also, das werden wir doch malen.
Das ist ja schließlich der Bundesnachricht.
Und es ist das Fachblatt für Datenreisen.
Wenn sie es nicht tun, dann haben sie ein Problem.
Das hatten sie easy bei der TV bekommen.
Ja, bevor wir dann mal ins Eingemachte gehen, noch ein Hinweis, wie wir zu empfangen sind. Außer UKW und den üblichen Satellitenverbindungen gibt es natürlich auch wieder ein MP3 Stream von uns, ein Real Audio Stream von Fritz. Wir haben ja auch ein Auge auf den IRC-Kanal, auf dem Server irc.freenote.net im Kanal Chaos Radio. Da könnt ihr irgendwie mit uns diskutieren und Hinweise fallen lassen. Und auch schon verfügbar ist die Information, zumindest die erste Information über den kommenden Kongress Ende des Jahres, wo natürlich auch solche THAC-Themen eine Rolle spielen, aber natürlich auch ganz viele andere Themen unter www.cccde.com und www.cccde.com. Das war es, LESCH 2004.
Fritz Info.
Die Nacht bleibt trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen auf Werte zwischen 14 und 8 Grad zurück. Morgen wird es dann richtig schön. Viel Sonne, ganz selten mal ein paar Quellwölkchen und kein Regen. Die Temperaturen klettern auf maximal 28 Grad. Und jetzt gibt es die weiteren Meldungen von Matthias Kertens.
Die Bundesregierung will für mehr Wettbewerb und Transparenz auf dem Strom- und Gasmarkt sorgen. Dafür verabschiedete das Bundeskabinett den Entwurf für ein neues Energiewirtschaftsgesetz. Das Gesetz zieht eine Überwachung des Wettbewerbs durch eine Regulierungsbehörde vor. Durch das neue Gesetz sollen auch die Strompreise sinken, heißt es. Der Prozess gegen den früheren Verteidigungsstaatssekretär Holger Pfalz kann möglicherweise bereits im September beginnen. Pfalz stimmte heute eine raschen Auslieferung nach Deutschland zu. Pfalz war vor zwei Wochen in Paris gefasst worden. Britische Soldaten sollen einen Gefangenen in einem Lager im Südirak zur Tode geprügelt haben. Das gab ein ehemaliger Mitgefangener vor dem obersten Gerichtshof in London an. Die Soldaten sollen noch mehrere andere Gefangene in einem britischen Militärlager bei Basra systematisch misshandelt haben. Die Hilfsorganisation Ärzte ohne Grenzen stellt nach 24 Jahren ihre Arbeit in Afghanistan endgültig ein. Laut der Organisationen sorge die afghanische Regierung nicht ausreichend für die Sicherheit der Mitarbeiter. Für zwei Monate waren fünf Mitarbeiter der Organisation ermordet worden. Der Verkehr auf Ritz hat keine Meldungen, gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias Karcov, zwei Minuten nach Adelf.
Ab sofort wünsche ich keinen Besuch mehr.
Ich bin Ken und wenn ich nicht Ken bin, dann bin ich im Urlaub.
Und was soll ich den Leuten sagen, die sie sprechen wollen?
Ken FM ist trotzdem nur eben ausgezeichnet.
Darf ich die Leute reinschicken, nachdem sie gegangen sind?
Sonntag zum Beispiel.
Dann sind sie aber nicht mehr hier, oder?
Gäste gibt es trotzdem. Martin Jondo, Mellow Mark und Moe Azumar.
Verstehe, Sir.
Komm bloß nicht vorbei, bleib aber live und man sieht sich, wenn man sich wieder sieht.
Auf Wiedersehen, Sir.
Guten Abend, Chaosradio 94 auf Fritz ist hier und jetzt geht es wirklich um unser Thema.
Genau, jetzt geht es um unser Thema.
Soll ich noch mal mit dem Tee hacken?
Ich sehe genug echauffiert, nein bitte nicht. Echauffiert? Amüsiert? Amüsiert, naja wie auch immer. Erhitzt.
Erhitzt, auch sehr schön.
Das gefällt mir.
Das haben wir.
Ja, fangen wir doch an zu schwellen. Genau, wir schwellen.
Ja, also Computer und Telefonie. Ich meine, Leute, die schon früh mit Computernetzwerken angefangen haben und vor allem mit DFU, wie das damals so schön hieß, hatten natürlich früh eigentlich auch schon so den Wunsch und die Idee, dann irgendwann auch mal so richtig Audio darüber zu machen. Da gab es dann auch die verschiedensten Ansätze, aber natürlich waren die ersten Computer alle nicht so richtig in der Lage, das überhaupt zu handeln. Also sie waren schlicht einfach zu langsam und Audio-Codecs waren auch damals noch keine Technologie, die wirklich verfügbar war, dass man die unglaubliche Datenmenge, die man braucht, um Sprache abzuspeichern, einfach nicht vorhanden war. Aber es war aber auch klar, dass man das wollte. Und es gab so erste Ansätze, die dann erstmal da begonnen haben, wo eben auch schon elektronische Geräte verwendet wurden. Anrufbeantworter zum Beispiel. Das heißt, die ersten Modems konnten nur Daten und dann gab es dann irgendwann auch Modems, die auch in der Lage waren, einen Voice-Call anzunehmen. Also die dann erkannt haben, ah, jetzt kommt hier kein Carrier-Signal, da ist kein Computer, der anruft.
Das war so bei US Robotics Sportster oder wie sie hießen, war das doch sogar Standard, oder?
Also ich glaube, die ersten waren Zeichsel. Da gab es irgendwie dieses 1496, dieses Blinketal mit dem LCD-Display, was alle ganz nifty fanden, weil es auch immer so schön den Status angezeigt hat. Das war ja auch schick, was auch irgendwie, glaube ich, das erste Gerät war, wo man so ein Firmware-Download machen konnte. Es ist alles schon so düster. Auf jeden Fall gab es einfach Modems, die das konnten.
Na wer sich erinnert, ist aufgefordert anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Vielleicht ist es ja bei irgendeinem von euch nicht ganz so düster wie bei uns.
Genau. Auch so eine ganz prägende Entwicklung waren dann so erste Steckkarten. Also es gab dann auch so erste Modems auf Steckkarten für PCs, dass man das eben nicht mehr so ran bimmelte, sondern eben also nicht über V24 oder so Anschluss, sondern eben direkt in den Computer reinsteckte, was ein paar Vor- und Nachteile hatte. Eins dieser Produkte ist zum Beispiel BigMouse gewesen, die war relativ günstig und kam halt auch gleich mit so einer Miniatur-Software für DOS, sodass man eben ein PC im Prinzip als Voice-Mailbox benutzen konnte für Leute, die da anrufen, anriefen, also mit so einem Menü und die dann auch schon so GTMF-Erkennung machen konnte. Nicht jedes Telefon hatte sowas. Teilweise haben die, glaube ich, sogar mit Impulswahl-Detection. Echt?
Ja, aber das war ja wirklich schon ein advancedes Feature, wenn ich es sicherer lernen darf. Das war ja wirklich sehr, sehr kompliziert.
Genau, aber im Wissen, also GTMF hatte natürlich in den USA eine ganz andere Verbreitung. Als in Deutschland zum Beispiel kam dann so, das waren auch so die Zeiten, wo man dann auch so einen speziellen Tongeber irgendwie noch dazu bekam.
Tongeber oder Programmieren, Sternchen programmieren am Telefon.
Genau, auch so die ersten Anrufbeantworter hatten sowas immer beiliegen. So ein Tongeber, ne?
Fernabfrage.
Genau, die Fernabfrage. Und eigentlich waren das immer diese DTMF-Dinger, also diese Doppelfrequenzcode, mit dem man halt da irgendwie so diese 0-9-Sternraute-ABCD codieren konnte. Und das war dann recht populär und viele Leute haben halt angefangen, solche Mailboxen aufzubauen und das war natürlich dann irgendwie auch Tempting, sodass in zunehmendem Maße auch eine Industrie dieses Bewusstsein hochkam, ah, wir können automatisierte Systeme bauen, die eben vollautomatisch einen Anrufer handeln und damit wollten sie dann eben Dienste realisieren, die ohnehin immer wieder das gleiche waren, womit halt Menschen überfordert waren. Eingabe von Kreditkarten, Nummern, Abfrage von Fahrplänen, Wetter, Informationen, wir kennen das ja alles. Und dann eben auch so diese etwas schlüpfrigeren Dienste, die natürlich dann auch sehr viel mehr Leute interessierten. Es gab da auch einen schönen Namen für, der war komisch, aber das ist nun mal der Begriff, Audiotex nannte man das, also ohne T hinten, also auch nur Audiotex, also Audio Technologies oder wie auch immer, keine Ahnung, wo das wirklich herkommt, aber das war dann so die Bezeichnung für diese Aufkalbenindustrie. Also wir reden jetzt über einen Zeitraum von 1992, Anfang der 90er Jahre.
Das ist aber im Prinzip jetzt die Sicht aus der Hobbyisten-Ecke, würde ich sagen. Also in Amerika hatte das Ganze schon sehr viel früher angefangen. Die Amerikaner waren im Prinzip dadurch gehandicapt, dass sie einen anderen Numbering Plan haben als hier.
Was ist was?
Also einen Rufnummerplan. Also du hast eine Telefonnummer und du könntest jetzt zum Beispiel, du hast ein ESDN-Telefon, dann hast du drei Telefonnummern oder du hast einen Hauptanschluss oder du hast ein Primärmultiplex und dann hast du einen ganzen Adressraum dahinter, also tausende von Telefonnummern. Das heißt, du kannst hier in Deutschland oder konntest schon immer eine Telefonanlage anschließen, warst unter einer zentralen Nummer erreichbar und hattest deine Durchwahl.
Das ging in den USA nicht.
Das geht dort heute noch nicht. Ach. Das hat die ganze Industrie natürlich ganz unglaublich nach vorne gebracht, weil jeder, absolut jede amerikanische Firma musste unbedingt einen Rezeptionisten haben. Und das ist natürlich ziemlich teuer und vielleicht sogar mehrere, weil die Firma so groß war und dann hat man versucht, das zu automatisieren. Und das hat man meines Erachtens schon in den 80er Jahren getan und über die Zeit, das war dann also für große Firmen, wo wirklich viele, viele Rezeptionisten, so zu sagen Telefonistinnen, da saßen und über die Zeit ist diese Technologie dann immer weiter standardisiert worden und ist dann auch nach meiner Erinnerung wirklich in den 90er Jahren dann tatsächlich bei den Hobbyisten angekommen. Und die erste Welle waren wirklich die Modems, dann kam Big Mouth und dann gab es diese Standardisierungsversuche, die Komponenten untereinander sprechen zu lassen, dass man dann auch ein Faxboard noch anschließen konnte und dann nicht nur Voice hatte, sondern auch wieder Fax und dann ging das Ganze auf Mehrkanaligkeit und natürlich ISDN. Damit waren dann plötzlich auf einmal zwei Rufnummern da. Da konnte man schon eine ganze Menge mitmachen, Konferenzen zum Beispiel, könnte man selber mischen und mit...
Vielleicht sollen wir kurz mal erläutern, wie das eigentlich konkret funktioniert. Wir reden halt Anfang der 90er Jahre, das war so 3-86er, war gerade so total hip und irgendwann so kam dann auch der 4-86er, halt immer wieder die nächste Höllenmaschine, wo man dann komplett...
33 MHz.
Auch diese Rechner waren noch nicht in der Lage, wirklich mit diesem ganzen Audio-Klumpatsch mitzukommen, aber ein PC taugt eigentlich ganz prima, also auch schon die damaligen taugten ganz prima, um eben so Sachen zu automatisieren, das heißt, man steckte da sauteure Erweiterungskarten rein, die im Prinzip dieses ganze Management der Telefonleitungen gemacht haben. Das kam natürlich alles aus den USA, war dann erstmal alles mit analogen Leitungen und die digitale Telefonie, wie wir sie in Europa kennen, vor allem in Deutschland mit ISDN, war da eigentlich vollkommen unbekannt. So, deren Digitalisierungsversuche des Telefonnetzes muten uns eigentlich eher ein bisschen holprig an. Da gibt es zum Beispiel dieses sagenumwobene T1 mit dieser Inband, kannst du das noch mal beschreiben?
T1, ja, da wollte ich noch ein Wort zu sagen, das ist wie gesagt ein Patent von 1900, ich glaube 68. Kann ich dir jemand anrufen und mich korrigieren?
Und das macht was?
Du hast ein Kupferdraht und kannst plötzlich über diesen Kupferdraht nicht nur ein Gespräch leiten, sondern plötzlich 24. Das war natürlich ganz toll, das war der Fortschritt. Damit hat das Ganze angefangen. Das war alles Pulsecode modulated und die Signalisierungsinformationen wurden im Audio Datenstrom übertragen. Da wurden einfach, ich glaube, bei jedem Enten, ich hab vergessen, einfach ein Bit geklaut und damit wurde A und B.
Da kommen nämlich diese komischen Datenraten, wenn man hier so einen ISDN PMXer macht, dann hat man da im Prinzip zwei Megabit drauf und mit der vergleichbaren Technologie gab's in den USA halt nur 1, 5 Megabit. Da fragt man sich mal, warum? Das lag einfach daran, dass sie einfach die Bits geklaut haben, um die ganze Zeit für jeden Kanal immer zu sagen, du bist aufgelegt oder du bist nicht aufgelegt. Also eine vollkommene Redundanz. Während irgendwie im europäischen System war das sehr viel digitaler, wo man einfach die Leitung getrennt hatte von dem Kontrollkanal, der halt ab und zu immer gesagt hat, und ab jetzt ist diese Leitung nicht mehr verbunden, so diese Signalisierung. Also das ist natürlich auch dann immer wieder so ein, das ist immer leichter auf die Amerikaner zu zeigen. Die hatten natürlich dann auch sehr viel früher auch eine sehr umfangreiche Telefonie und man hängt dann auch immer ein bisschen im System, genauso wie mit TV, so auf der anderen Seite fallen ihnen dann andere Schritte wiederum leichter. Aber trotzdem war natürlich auch ISDN eigentlich ein sehr wichtiger Trend. Also man hat hier eigentlich früh erkannt, dass diese Digitalisierung wichtig ist, um einfach auch die Steuerung durch Computer besser vornehmen zu können. ISDN war ja hier eigentlich in den 90er Jahren ziemlich hit. Fast jeder hat eigentlich irgendwie einen ISDN-Anschluss, also nicht jeder, aber auf jeden Fall sehr viele im Vergleich zu den USA, wo das immer nur so eine Nebenerscheinung war und das gibt es auch heute noch nicht so richtig. Und dieses ISDN war eigentlich recht, naja, recht versatil, also man kann da viel mit machen. Das alte Vision, ISDN, Integrated Services, Digital Network, alles über ein Netzbild, Telefonie, la la la, konnte sich immer keiner so richtig vorstellen, kam ja dann auch nie, weil es eigentlich mal viel zu früh war. Trotzdem war es sehr praktisch für Computer, wenn man so eine ISDN-Karte in seinen PC rein tut, dann ist es dem Computer sehr einfach zu erkennen, wann kommt ein Anruf, wann ist der zu Ende, das ist mit Analog gar nicht so einfach und man kann auch gleich die Rufnummer sehen, also sowas wie Caller-ID nennt man das dann in den USA, sodass man sieht, wer anruft, das ist da ein richtiges Feature anhand, die sich alles Mögliche einfallen lassen, wie man das machen kann mit DTMF-Signalen, die dann noch von der Telefonanlage hinterher geschmissen werden und so ein ganzer Voodoo, was einfach bei dem ISDN komplett wegfiel. Von daher war das eigentlich weit überlegen und ist jetzt, naja, durch Internet fällt es jetzt wieder so ein bisschen hinten raus, da kommen wir ja im Prinzip auch auf die Spur mit unserer Sendung. Trotzdem ist ISDN ein Riesenerfolg, das ist auch die Basis für GSM, also für Mobiltelefonie, im Prinzip ist alles was heute Telefonie macht und kein amerikanisches System ist, ein Nachfahre von ISDN.
Chaosradio 94 auf Fritz, Telefonieren mit Computer, mittels Computern, durch Computer. Im Studio der Harald, Harald sag mal hallo. Der Lars, der hat ein Mikrofon.
Genau, hallo.
Und der Tim sowieso.
Ja, ich hab auch ein Mikrofon.
Wunderbar.
Ja.
Wo waren wir stehen? Wir waren im ISDN.
Ja, wir neigen mal wieder zum technischen Detail, so ganz unwichtig ist es nicht. Tatsache ist, das Telefonnetz war eigentlich damals recht faszinierend. Das Telefonnetz ist ja auch das Urnetz der Hacker. Also das eigentliche, auch der politische Aspekt des Hackings hat sich ja so damals in 60er Jahren mit der Auseinandersetzung des Telefonnetzes so begründet. Also das Phone Freaking, die Phone Freaks, also Freaks, die sich mit PHA schrieben, wo dann auch solche Zeitungen wie die Frac auch mit PHA bei raus kamen. Das war damals im Vietnamkrieg auch eine der Widerstandsmethoden. Das heißt, es gab einfach eine aufgeklärte Minderheit, die gesagt hat, wir wollen diesen Krieg nicht finanzieren, aber wir finanzieren ihn mit jedem Telefongespräch, weil die Big Bell, die nimmt irgendwie die Kohle ein und so geht es ja nun gar nicht. Und deswegen haben sie Methoden herausgefunden.
Das war eine ziemlich billige Ausrede, um sonst zu telefonieren, oder?
Na ja, billige Ausrede, das war schon eine politisch eingestellte Szene. Das kann man also nicht verneinen. Und deswegen haben sie sich dann natürlich auch das spielerische, was sich ja immer paart beim Hacking. Also immer vom Spieltrieb zur Wissbegier kommt man irgendwie so vorwärts und will irgendwie einfach herausfinden, wie es ist. Und das Ganze ist dann eben auch so ein bisschen getrieben durch dieses jetzt zeigen wir es denen. Es ist ja auch einfach so dieses, hatten wir ja schon Teehack und so, es macht natürlich Spaß den Großen dann immer wieder eins auszuwischen und dass das Telefonsystem damals eben einfach das Omnipräsente und so einfach, wie das ja hier auch ist mit der Telekom, einfach die Telekommunikationsfirmen waren einfach diejenigen, die einfach Zeit und Luft für Geld verkauft haben und da musste man ran. Da gibt es ja diese legendäre Geschichte zum Beispiel hier mit Captain Crunch. Man kann es irgendwie fast nicht mehr hören, aber das gehört halt alles dazu, der herausgefunden hat, dass man mit so einer Plastikpfeife, die man in so einer Cornflakes Packung findet, eben dieser Captain Crunch Packung, wenn man da irgendwie reinpfeift in die Telefonleitungen, wurden dann eben die Mitzähler für die Gebührenabrechnung einfach ausgeschaltet. War so ein Feature für die Mitarbeiter, sodass man also einfach in eine Public Telefonzelle reingehen konnte. Man pfeift irgendwie in dieser Plastikpfeife rein und dann konnte man eben kostenlos weiter telefonieren oder zumindest ohne weiteres Geld zu bezahlen. Und von daher war das Telefonnetz schon immer auch im Mittelpunkt des Hackings. Das hat auch extreme internationale Züge gehabt. Schon bevor, also heute ist man das ja gewohnt. Internet und so, ja, und dann habe ich in Alaska was gehackt, in Japan eingedrungen und die NASA und so. Man kann es ja gar nicht mehr hören. Aber das gab es halt vorher schon mit Telefonnetzen. Da gibt es aberwitzige Geschichten von Leuten, die dann auch solche Späße gemacht haben, dass sie sich irgendwie in Chile bei, dass sie sich in diese Geschichte, dass sie sich dann so Faxe gefälscht haben. Faxe ist ja auch nochmal so ein Thema. Ja, bitte, wir brauchen mal eine neue Trunk-Leitung. Irgendwie schaltet uns das doch bitte. Chile war halt relativ früh da was liberalisiert. Deswegen waren da irgendwie viele Firmen und dann haben sie dann so getan, als wären sie ein amerikanisches Telekom-Unternehmen. Und die haben dann gesagt, ja prima und so. Wir brauchen aber irgendwie einen Bestätigungsfax und nennen es uns irgendwie ein amerikanischer Rufnummer, wo wir es zurückschicken können. Dann haben die einfach so eine Gateway-Box da in den USA kurz gemacht. Das heißt, die haben das tatsächlich in die USA gefaxed. Aber es wurde dann hinten raus aus dem Computer dann wieder nach Deutschland zurückgefaxed. Und dann haben die sich einfach so internationale Leitungen freischalten lassen, auf denen sie dann auch wieder kostenlos telefonieren. Also die mussten ja nicht die ganze Zeit telefonieren. Es ist einfach so der Spaß, dass man das eben auch kostenlos machen kann. Und Telefonsystem war einfach immer schon im Mittelpunkt.
Bin so sicher und entdecktiv. Chaosradio 94, telefonieren mit Computern. Lars, was wolltest du noch erzählen?
Ich wollte jetzt einfach mal so die Geschichte in einen zeitlichen Rahmen spannen. Und zwar wann das überhaupt jetzt beim ISDN gekommen ist. Und das fing an 1979, da hat sich die Deutsche Bundespost entschieden, damals noch Bundespost, die Vermittlungsstellen zu digitalisieren. 80 haben sie dann angefangen, hat CCITT heute die ITU angefangen, die Richtlinien für ISDN festzulegen.
Vielleicht kurz noch dazu, was das ist, die ITU oder die CCITT. Das ist also das Gremium, was zumindest damals in Europa mittlerweile weltweit Standards definiert, die mit dem Telefonsystem zusammenhängen.
Also ITU steht für International Telecommunications Union. Das sind die ganzen großen bösen Magentafarben, die das Geld aufteilen.
Die geheime Weltregierung, die theologischen Ströme lenkt.
Aber die halt auch Standards festlegen, ISDN war halt einer davon.
Die sitzen in Genf und wenn man auf so eine ITU Telekom Messe geht, dann wundert man sich sehr. Da sind also Telekoms aus allen Herren Ländern da. Und im Wesentlichen, die Funktion der ITU ist tatsächlich auch das Interworking festzuklopfen, sodass ich auch wirklich problemlos von hier eben nach Chile jetzt telefonieren kann. Jetzt muss ich bezahlen, aber das macht die ITU und das ist dementsprechend reine Politik eigentlich. Es geben aber technische Standards heraus und die haben an diesen Standards gearbeitet. Wirklich so zwischen 1982 bis... es wird immer noch beim gearbeitet, aber da hat es im Ernst angefangen.
Wo also ISDN im Prinzip eingeführt wurde, so richtig durchgesetzt hat sich es dann eigentlich erst in den 90er Jahren. Dann wurden dann eben auch europaeinheitliche Standards festgelegt, la la la Euro, ISDN, solche Sachen. Das war dann auch so die Geburtsstunde dieser ganzen billigen ISDN-Karten.
Wurde ja massiv subventioniert damals, als das Euro ISDN in Deutschland eingeführt wurde. Vorher gab es das sogenannte 1TR6, das nationale ISDN der Bundespost.
Ich finde es einfach so klasse, in eure zynisch grinsenden Gesichter zu gucken.
1TR6 ist eine typische Telekom Abkürzung. TR steht einfach für Technische Richtlinie.
Telekom Abkürzung, da gibt es richtig schöne. Wie war das Ö-Kartell, das öffentliche Kartentelefon?
Hier, Telekom Abkürzung abliefern unter 0331 70 97 110.
Den Fet-Ampf gibt es ja auch, den ganzen guten alten Telefonerwart.
Falls jemand von euch da draußen mit Computer-Mailboxen gearbeitet hat früher, also was weiß ich, Audio-Mailboxen betrieben hat oder mit Voice-Modems rumgespielt hat und so und da was lustiges zu erzählen hat, dann bitte unter 0331 70 97 110 anrufen.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht Telefon-Treff-Düren. Also ich kann mich daran erinnern, es gab da mal den Telefon-Treff-Düren.
Genau, das war doch ein normaler Konferenz-Prototyp der Pilotprojekte.
Das war aber doch eine normale Konferenz-Schaltung, oder nicht?
Damals war es nämlich, also die Telekom, das ist eine dieser Sinnlosigkeiten. Also abgesehen davon, dass es verboten war, also strafrechtlich verboten war, ein Modem physikalisch an das Telefonnetz anzuschließen, weil das ja ein hoheitlicher Akt ist.
Und das Endgerät der Telekom gehörte?
Genau, war es auch nicht erlaubt, Vermittlungsdienstleistungen bereitzustellen. Ja, weil das war ja das Monopol. Das bedeutet auch, dass man eben nicht einen Computer betreiben durfte, auf dem dann auf zehn Telefonleitungen Leute anrufen und sie wurden dann einfach zusammengeschaltet in einer Konferenz. Also einfach so ein Audio-Chat war schlicht nicht erlaubt. Klingt abenteuerlich, aber war ein Problem. Durfte nur die Telekom, die hat das dann auch gemacht, das war die... Er hat ja Recht.
Warte mal, wo wir gerade bei Post sind, ein kurzer Zwischenruf per Telefon. Thorsten.
Ja, ein Mönchennamen, Thorsten hier.
Ja, du hast ein paar Abkürzungen.
Und zwar, ich hab mal gelernt bei Telekom, ja. Auslärm 95, und zwar eine VVD-UP.
VVD-UP?
Ja, Verteiler und Verbinderdose Unterputz. Oder ein KVZ, das ist ein Kabelfahrtzweier. Das sind die Kisten, die auf der Straße stehen.
Das gibt auch den AVADO.
Und da gibt's doch ein EVZ. Das ist der Endfahrtzweier. Das ist der, der im Prinzip am Haus ist.
Was war denn AVADO? AVADO?
Das ist eine alte Telekom-Dose, eine AVADO. Und zwar ist das so eine Dose, wo im Prinzip der Stecker nicht gesteckt werden kann, sondern er ist fest installiert.
Also einfach nur ein Kabel in der Wand.
Genau, ein Kabel in der Wand. TZ Gustav, also Theodor Zeppelin Gustav. Und zwar Tonruf 2-Kilometer.
Entschuldige, dafür kriegst du einen Tusch. Warte mal eben, warte mal eben.
Ein Telefon hatten mit der zweiten, mit der zweiten Ort, wo halt eine Klingel rein musste, gab's dafür halt die Möglichkeit, da ist nur eine Klingel dagegen gewesen, die extra geklingelt hat. Und dann gab's noch ein SAR. Es gab die Sache, dass im Prinzip ein Telefon die Klingel hat, gerade in einer lauten Werkstatt, musste irgendwo eine Lampe angehen. Und da wurde so ein SAR zwischengeschaltet.
Sag noch mal, was heißt TZG nochmal auf Deutsch?
Tonruf Zweitgerät.
Thorsten, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tonruf Zweitgerät gefällt mir eigentlich so am besten so weit bis jetzt.
Ja, ich weiß noch nicht genau, was es ist, aber...
Chaosradio 94, jetzt gehe ich immer noch um Telekom, Entschuldigung. Telefonieren mit Computern. Telefonieren mit Computern und wir waren Stingedümer. Im Telefonteft Dürren und der zumindest juristischen Unmöglichkeit im Netz der Bundespost Konferenzschaltungen zu machen. Warum durften die das in Dürren denn dann machen?
Weil das die Telekom selber gemacht hat. Das war halt ein Pilotprojekt. Sowas wird ja dann immer großrankig gefeiert und anstatt es einfach mal zu erlauben, sowas natürlich nicht getan haben, weil es so automatisch sozusagen ihr eigentlich das Vermittlungsmonopol durchbrachen hätte und auch sofort missbraucht worden wäre gar keine Frage, aber es war halt eh affig. Haben sie dann dann immer solche Pilotprojekte gestartet, wie man das auch heute noch macht? Wahrscheinlich hat das System mehrere Millionen Mark gekostet, vermute ich mal, wissen tue ich es nicht, aber ist ja aufwendig.
Ja, aber dafür gab es immer einen Gong, wenn ein neuer sich eingewählt hat. Ich komme da aus der Gegend und wir haben früher einfach immer breit faixtend zu Hause gesessen, mit dem Lautsprecher angemacht und haben gesagt, bellen wir uns da mal ein. Und haben dann beim Telefonteff Dürren gelauscht und es hat immer gemacht Gong und dann sagten alle, ja wer ist denn da neu?
Und wenn du nichts gesagt hast, dann haben die halt immer gesagt, lass mich raten, sind irgendwelche Frauen hier?
Nein, nein, das hatte so was ein bisschen von so einem geschlossenen IRC-Kanal. Das heißt, die kannten sich alle und haben dann eben ja Belanglosigkeiten ausgetauscht. Also im Grunde IRC, Audio-IRC.
CB-Funk.
CB-Funk, ja so ähnlich. Und das war schon ein bisschen schrecklich. Und da waren dann eben echt so die Leute, die auch heute im Heiseforum schreiben, die waren damals schon am Telefon in dieser Konferenz.
Wie war das denn die Gesprächskultur?
Das war wirklich freundlich, diese Flamerei oder sowas, das gab es überhaupt nicht.
Das waren die frühen Systeme, ja genau.
Damals, als die Leute noch Anstand hatten.
Ja, da war das auch neu und so und dann war man irgendwie froh, da überhaupt teilzunehmen und die Leute, die das gefunden haben, waren natürlich dann auch glücklich. Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Aber ich habe da nie angerufen, weil es war halt einfach nur eine Konferenzschaltung. Das fand ich jetzt nicht so schön.
Na ja, wir haben dann...
Ich wusste mit dem C64 nichts anderes zu machen als zu spielen. Also ich fand das richtig irre.
Ja, wir hatten ja auch, etwa zu der Zeit war dann ja auch die Villa. Da hatten ja Tim und ich dran rumgeschraubt.
Das war dann schon ein bisschen professioneller, ne?
Was heißt professioneller? Das war ein etwas anderer Ansatz.
Ich konnte eben da rumlaufen in der Konferenz.
Ja, es gab eigentlich erstmal gar keine Konferenz. Das war eigentlich das Besondere. Also wir hatten ja die Villa schon mal vor, ich habe keine Ahnung wann wir das mal gemacht haben. Irgendwann hatten wir das hier schon mal. Aber die Villa war halt eine verrückte Idee, mit der damals zur Verfügung stehenden Audio-Text-Technologie, diese Steckkarten, die man halt in den Rechner reinstecken kann, möglichst großes System zu bauen, wo eben alle so in einer Welt sind. Also diese übliche Abenteuer-Idee, wie man das auch so in Text-Adventures und so weiter hat. Audio-Math. Genau, so ein Math, wo man halt, genau, wir hatten das in der Chat-Sendung, genau, das war's. Ah, stimmt. Und da passt es auch gut rein. Aber es passt auch gut zur Telefonie, weil es war halt alles nur Telefonie. Das heißt, man hat angerufen und dann war man eben drinnen im System. Bloß man hat dann eben jegliche Interaktion über die Tonwahl mit dem Programm gemacht. Und andere Leute haben das auch getan. Man war dann eben so scheinbar in einer Villa und konnte sich dann eben von Raum zu Raum bewegen. In den Kloor, im Speisesitzzimmer, in den Kühlschrank einschließen, ins Stammklo, du bist im Damenklo, Holo. Genau, oder im Kühlschrank. Hier hatte es seinen eigenen Schreibtisch und es gab eigentlich so alle, alle Systeme.
Moment, man konnte in den Kühlschrank gehen, aber nur zwei, er war nicht so groß.
Für private Gespräche.
Als er im Stammklo besetzt war wahrscheinlich. Da konnten auch nur zwei.
Aber auch Herren.
Da haben wir nicht unterschieden.
Da rufen wir jetzt mal an.
Wir können ja gleich mal anrufen. Läuft ja schon seit einiger Zeit nicht mehr. Wir haben sie jetzt irgendwie, beziehungsweise Lars hat sie re-kultiviert, animiert. Ich weiß nicht, wie würdest du es nennen?
Reanimation passt da glaube ich ganz gut.
Genau, also man muss permanent den Herzschrittmacher irgendwie anlegen.
So eine Bastelstube in meinem Keller ist das, da läuft die im Moment.
Worüber ist das verschüttet gegangen? Hat keiner mehr angerufen?
Es war ja mal gedacht, da wirklich einen kommerziellen Dienst draus zu machen. Das war ja nicht für andere Schweinereien geplant. Die Villa war eher ein Unfall. Und dann lief es aber dann trotzdem eine Weile und war halt ganz beliebt, vor allem bei CB-Funkern und Blinden aber auch anderen Leuten. Die hatten da alle ja einen Spaß und es war auch immer voll. Es waren 60 Leute, die da irgendwie rumgelaufen sind und kommuniziert haben. Weil es gab alles, was man eigentlich auch im Internet so kennt. Es gab persönliche Post, es gab öffentliche Foren, man hat was ins Gästebuch geschrieben, man hat irgendwie an seinem Schreibtisch seine Post gelesen. Man konnte aber auch so Instant-Messaging-mäßig direkt den Leuten, die halt online sind, also die auch gerade in der Villa rumliefen, direkt alle Nachrichten zukommen lassen. Also im Prinzip war die Villa so ein Mikrokosmos aller typischen Kommunikationsformen. Außerdem war halt noch ein bisschen Abenteuer mit drin. Man konnte in den Fahrstuhl gehen, auf Knöpfe drücken, Dinge finden, ein Megafon da irgendwie reinsprechen, dann konnten das alle hören. Und dann für die Leute, die da so ein bisschen Housekeeping gemacht haben, die sich da besonders freundlich hervorgetan haben, die Interesse hatten, dass irgendwie Systeme in Griff zu halten, die haben dann auch so soziale Steuerungsmaßnahmen übernommen.
Digital Ohrfeige?
Nö, ja andersrum. Wenn einer irgendwie laut schreit, dann wird er einfach stimmgeschaltet.
Oh, doch, doch, doch, die digitale Ohrfeige gibt es. Also ich weiß jetzt leider nicht, wie man sie auslöst, aber das gab es. Also ein Soundeffekt war da schon drin. Man konnte als Supervisor da irgendwie Sternen-0, irgendwas, so eine Raute drücken und dann hat das ein Bartschengeräusch gegeben. Was der Villa sicherlich das Genick gebrochen hat, war die Tatsache, dass es damals nur über 190er kommerziell zu betreiben war. Und 190er war wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig teuer. Das wurde zum Schluss nur noch verwendet für Sexlines im Prinzip, nur noch für Pornografie.
Also ich würde auch nie eine 0190 wählen, selbst wenn ich etwas Seriöses anrufen wollte.
Also gegen Ende lief es ja auch auf billigeren Nummern.
Ja, aber das hat sehr lange gedauert. Mittlerweile ist es ja durchaus so, dass wenn man einen Anschluss in einem Netz eines Telefonbetreibers hat, ein oder zwei PMXer und da wirklich viel Verkehr erzeugt, dann kriegt man tatsächlich von den Ortsgebühren noch ein ganz, ganz kleines bisschen ab.
PMXer sind 30 Telefonleitungen über ISDN.
So jetzt haben wir über die Villa geredet, Lars hat extra die Villa.
Dann schaltest du ein Mikro aus, oder?
Reanimiert, warum? Achso, ja, genau, dann schalte ich mal sein Mikro aus. Ne, das war ja nicht deins.
Aber einen willst du wahrscheinlich dran haben.
So, dann wollen wir mal die Villa anrufen, damit sich auch alle möglicherweise das drunter vorstellen können.
So, ich mach mal Musik leider.
Jetzt ist doch schon wieder die Nummer geklickt.
Wenn du schon Villa-Bewohner bist, drücke bitte die Taste 1 auf deinem Telefon.
Bin ich Villa-Bewohner?
Wenn du Gast bist und noch mal reinschauen möchtest, dann drücke die Taste 2. Wenn du das erste Mal anrufst, helfe ich dir. Drücke die 3 oder wenn du keine Tasten hast, warte einfach ab. Wenn du schon Villa-Bewohner bist, drücke die Taste 1 auf deinem Telefon. Wenn du Gast bist und noch mal reinschauen möchtest, dann drücke die Taste 2. Wenn du das erste Mal anrufst, helfe ich dir.
Wir brauchen ein Tongeber-Zweitgerät. Matthias, hast du zufällig vom Anrufbeantworter so ein Piepsding? Geht das nicht mit dem Telefon, mit dem Handy?
Geht das nicht mit dem Mikrofon?
Nee, ich bin nicht im ausgeschaltetem Zustand bestimmt.
Ja, also ich kann jetzt rein drücken. Aber warte mal, vielleicht schießt sie ja so rein.
Warte einfach ab, damit die Villa halten kann. Aha. Du hast es geschafft. Du kannst dir, wenn du möchtest, einen Spitznamen geben.
Spitznamen, jetzt.
Holgi!
Jetzt heißt du Holgi.
Ich bin in der Villa.
Wenn du immer wartest, dann kommt das Thema mal auf dich zu und hilft dir mit einer bestimmten Verzögerung. Also wenn du irgendwie nicht weißt, dann einfach warten.
Gibt es halt so Tipps. Der Clou ist mit der Bewegung.
Also du rückst immer die 5 und die Tasse, die du danach drückst, ist sozusagen die Richtung. Also wenn du jetzt 5, 2 machst, dann gehst du nach vorne. Das war ein bisschen viel.
Hat er nicht gesagt, ich soll 5, 6, 5, 6 sein?
Hier liegen ein paar kleine Zettelchen drin, die dir die Villa erklären.
Hier hängt ein Setzkasten mit den Informationen, die für dein Leben in der Villa wichtig sind.
Das ist ein bisschen im Setzkasten, das ist langweilig. Ich geh mal lieber noch mal mit 5, 4.
Willkommen in der Villa, dem verrückten Haus.
Hier kannst du sein, wer...
Wo bin ich denn jetzt?
Wir sind im Speiserraum.
Was ist das für ein System?
Das System kommt immer zuvor in dem Moment, wo du Lust brauchst.
Geh noch mal nach links.
Wie ist das denn? 5, 4 oder? Hey, ich fange an, das zu begreifen.
Du hörst auch die Tönen klappen, wenn andere Leute rein oder raus gehen.
Jetzt geh mal zweimal nach vorne, also 5,2,5,2.
Zwei.
Das Einzige blöde ist, ich komme jetzt nicht rein. Ich versuche mal meine Frau anzurufen, dass die für dich reingeht.
Also du bist jetzt quasi allein, das ist natürlich ein bisschen witzlos. Wobei jetzt kriegen wir nochmal diesen Bezug zu dieser Konferenzgeschichte. Das durften wir ja nicht machen. Es war auch ein technisches Problem, weil wir dazu eben teure Konferenzkarten machen. Und es hatte auch noch ganz andere technische Probleme, weswegen das gar nicht wünschenswert war. Und was wir dann ausgedacht haben, war so eine Walkie-Talkie-Geschichte, die eine interessante soziale Folge hatte, weil das so ähnlich dann funktioniert wie ein Text-Chat. Weil du drückst die Vier, sagst was, kannst mal machen, drückst nochmal die Vier, sagst was, drückst nochmal die Vier.
Übrigens musst du nicht warten, bis ich fertig bin. Schlag mir doch mal 5-5-5.
Und jetzt kann ich was sagen, bla bla bla. Und dann drücke ich nochmal die Vier.
Dann drückst du nochmal die Vier. Und das hat jetzt natürlich wenig Effekt, weil du es ja schon gesagt hast, aber alle anderen, die halt im Raum sind, würden es jetzt auch hören.
Ach so.
Wenn viele Leute im Raum reden und das tun, dann schachtelt sich das und queet sich. Genauso wie im Chat, die Textnachrichten sich aneinander rein. Und wenn eben viele Leute reden, hören dann auch alle auf zu reden, weil eben zu viel kommt, sodass sich automatisch der Gesprächslevel dann anpasst. Aber das Schöne ist, das macht halt alles der Computer. Tatsächlich waren es irgendwie zwei Computer, die das gesteuert haben. So einer, der sich so ein bisschen um die Logik und den Überbau gekümmert hat, und der andere einfach um die Telefonleiter.
Wann sind wir jetzt? 1900 wie viel?
1993 hatten wir das, 1994... 10 Jahre ist das Ding alt.
Bin ich da jetzt immer noch alleine?
Ja, ich versuche meine Frau da rein zu bekommen. Ich komme jetzt von hier auch nicht rein, das ist das Problem. Wieso nicht? Ich glaube, ich habe meine Telefonanlage misskonfiguriert. Ist das peinlich?
Na ja, wir haben es gezeigt.
Wir haben es gezeigt. Reanimiert ihr die irgendwann noch mal? Zur 100.
Wir wollten sie eigentlich zum Kongress auch mal reanimieren. Oder vielleicht auch schon vorher, je nachdem, wann sie ausreichend reanimiert ist. Weil es ist eigentlich ein schönes System, um sich zu treffen. Man kann es halt einfach mit einem Telefon benutzen. Man braucht keinen Computer, keinen Laptop, keinen WLAN. Man kann einfach Telefon nehmen und es ist irgendwie ganz praktisch. Und keine Nachrichten hinterlassen.
Ja, wir können immer zur 100. Sendung.
Spätetestens.
Auch für den öffentlichen Zugriff dann.
Das machen wir mal.
Ja, das schaffen wir.
Warum ist denn hier die Musik aus? Kaum geht Tim raus, ist die Musik aus, das Leben ist wirklich hart. Chaos Radio 94, ja da kommt sie wieder, die Musik. Chaos Radio 94, das ist was ihr hört hier auf Fritz. Und es geht um Telefonieren mit dem Computer, nicht nur mit dem Computer als Telefonpartner, sondern auch zum Telefonieren den Computer nehmen.
Richtig, genau. Das ist jetzt so der nächste Schritt. Es gibt da durchaus unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, wie man jetzt eine Telefonleitung irgendwie an den Computer anschließen kann. Bei analogen Telefonleitungen gibt es sogenannte zum Beispiel Line-Check- oder Phone-Check-Karten, wo man einfach eine analoge Telefonleitung an den Rechner anschließen kann und dann über den Computer telefonieren kann, mit einem Headset, über die Soundkarte, wie auch immer, den Computer zum Telefonieren verwenden.
Kann man auch direkt ein Telefon anschließen oder nicht?
Ja, das ist aber zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, man hat dann Software und man kann automatisch wählen.
Klingelspannung ist 60 Volt, damit kann man seine Katze elektrokutieren. Also das kannst du nicht so ohne weiter.
Elektrokutieren, was ist das? Also du meinst, der Katze ein Telefon geben und anrufen?
Das ist nicht lieb, also dann freut sie sich gleich.
Nein, ich wollte es nur wissen, aus dokumentarischen Gründen.
Ja, man merkt es auch. Wenn man zwei so Telefonkabel in der Hand hat und da ruft gerade jemand an, das merkt man dann doch relativ deutlich.
Jaja, das ist ziemlich heftig. Das ist im Wesentlichen, so wie ich das sehe, das und natürlich die unglaubliche Unzuverlässigkeit dieser analogen Hardware war das wesentliche Problem. Es gab eine ganze Menge analoge Karten. Groß auf dem Markt war Dialogic.
Das sind jetzt die kommerziellen Karten für größere Einsätze mit vielen Leitungen. Was es immer noch gibt und in den USA auch tatsächlich populär sind, sind diese von der Firma Quicknet zum Beispiel vertriebenen Linecheck-Phonecheck-Karten, wo man also als Einzelanwender das an seinen Telefonanschluss anschließen kann und dann eben zum Beispiel das Wählen aus dem Rechner heraus machen kann. Ist natürlich alles äußerst beschränkt. Richtig interessant wird das in der Kombination mit ISDN. ISDN als tatsächlich digitaler Telefonanschluss, der verträgt sich dann mit dem Computer auch viel besser. Und sobald ich jetzt eine ISDN-Karte in einem PC-Zone habe, dann ist alles weitere, was ich damit machen kann, eigentlich nur noch von der Software abhängig, ob ich da jetzt darüber telefoniere oder Fax versende, was auch immer. Die Integration ist da dann eigentlich relativ unbeschränkt. Es gibt auch diverse andere Lösungen, wo man eine Art externes Telefon, hat das nochmal über USB mit dem PC verbunden ist, wo man da nur wählen kann, aber eigentlich die Sprachinformation nach wie vor über das Telefon geht. Für ISDN gibt es natürlich auch zahlreiche sogenannte TK-Anlagen. Das sind dann kleine Telefonieanlagen, wo ich meine drei, vier Telefone anschließen kann, für die Leute, die auch unbedingt am Klo oder in der Küche ein Telefon brauchen. Diese TK-Anlagen bieten meistens dann auch die Anschlussmöglichkeit an den PC, wo ich dann sozusagen auch wieder die Schnittstelle habe und irgendwelche Audiodaten aus dem PC aufs Telefon bekomme oder umgekehrt. Ich kann dann eben damit sowohl ausgehende Telefone machen, als auch eingehend zum Beispiel Anrufbeantworter-Software laufen lassen oder eben auch solche ganzen Voice-Mailbox-Systeme programmieren, wie im Prinzip eine kleine Villa oder was auch immer.
Ja, ich glaube, die meisten Leute haben sich wirklich einfach erstmal ihre Anrufbeantworter und ihre Voiceboxen geschrieben.
Richtig, ja. Also gibt es für alle gängigen Betriebssysteme Anrufbeantworter-Software. Und wenn ich das in einem Programm realisiere, statt dass ich mir so ein Anrufbeantworter-Gerät hinstelle, dann habe ich halt eine ganz viel größere Flexibilität. Ich kann dann so Dinge machen wie unterschiedliche Ansagen, je nachdem von welcher Telefonnummer aus gerade angerufen wird.
Welche Uhrzeit.
Welche Uhrzeit. Ich kann die aufzuzeichnende Länge, also wie lange jemand drauf sprechen kann, auch dann wieder in Abhängigkeit machen von wer anruft. Oder nachdem wievielten Klingeln hingegangen wird, kann ich nachts nach dem ersten Klingeln schon machen. Oder bevor es überhaupt klingelt und tagsüber erst nach dem fünften Klingeln. So diese ganzen Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten, die habe ich natürlich.
Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich habe Hoffniss, aber manchmal ist es schon.
Mit Sicherheit gibt es einen Markt dafür. Es gibt sogar einen Markt für Klingeltöne.
Ja, das funktioniert super. Die haben eine riesige Datenbank gebaut und ihre eigenen Algorithmen, um das kurz zu vergleichen.
Das ist dann die Software, die dann auch so für GEMA-Verletzungen dann auch eingesetzt wird, richtig?
Oh, das ist jetzt die Idee. Darüber habe ich nicht nachgedacht.
Ja, es gibt so Systeme, die halt einfach Radio hören oder irgendwie... Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen.
Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen. Ich dachte schon, ich hätte das sagen müssen.
Kannst du dem Gerät nicht sagen?
Äh, ja, das blendet auch hier.
Ich hör da nichts von.
Ich kann fast gar nichts mehr sehen, aber kann ja hier nichts für dich veraugen.
Achso, ich meinte jetzt Blende im Sinne von Blende.
Im Sinne von Blende?
Ja, nicht im Sinne von Reflexion.
Ich hab hier ein 2 Sekunden Crossfade Playback, wenn du das meinst. Wenn du möchtest, kann ich ihn gerne noch auf 3 oder 4 Sekunden hochsetzen.
Naja, wenn wir jedes Mal eine Lücke haben und dann hier panisch irgendwelche Leute reingekommen und sagen, oh oh.
Telefonanlagen. Das ist natürlich ein tolles Thema, weil man braucht ja welche. Und wenn man sich so richtig überlegt, was so eine Telefonanlage heute ist, dann stellt man fest, das ist eigentlich auch alles nur noch ein Computer. Die schließt man ja auch schon an PC an, um sie zu konfigurieren. Mehr oder weniger elegant. Erst mit blöden Windows-Programmen, die man dann irgendwie installieren muss. Und wenn man kein Windows hat, dann kann man sie nicht benutzen.
Doch, in dem du so 28-stelliger Zahlencode-Sternchen eingibst, um dem Ding zu sagen, ich weiß, wovon ich spreche, mein Lieber.
Genau, und heute probieren sie es halt mit Webinterfaces, aber geben sich auch jede Mühe, das so sehr vom Internet Explorer abhängig zu machen, dass man kautzen könnte. Wie auch immer, es gibt Alternativen, es gibt auch Alternativen im freien Softwarebereich.
Ja, da hat sich einiges getan in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren. Und zwar ist die Idee einfach, dass man jetzt nicht eine TK-Anlage kauft, die eigentlich nichts anderes ist als drei, vier Interfaces zu so einer ISDN-Leitung hin, also zu dem sogenannten S0-Bus und einem kleinen Mikrocontroller, sondern man macht das einfach in Software. Das heißt, man steckt sich in seinen PC drei, vier ISDN-Karten rein und hat dann eben eine Software laufen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel das PBX for Linux-Projekt für Linux-Anwender, die dann diese Software, die die Aufgabe der TK-Anlage übernimmt und dann kann ich natürlich die Software eben auch vielfältig konfigurieren und zwischen unterschiedlichen ISDN-Telefonen vermitteln, Konferenzschaltungen machen, eingehende Anrufe auf Internettelefone zuordnen und so weiter und so weiter. Das ist aber alles noch eine reine Telefonieanwendung. Mittlerweile ist natürlich das Internet auch allgegenwärtig. Diese ganzen Sachen wie die Villa und was wir vorhin in der Vergangenheit erwähnt haben, war ja alles vor der verbreiteten Nutzung des Internets. Und dann kommt das Schlagwort auf, das sogenannte VoIP, das Voice-over-IP, was an und für sich erstmal ein Überbegriff ist für alle möglichen Technologien, die Sprachdaten über das Internet transportieren. Und sowas kann ich dann integrieren mit einer solchen TK-Anlage. Und dann bin ich bei Software, die sich z.B. nennt Asterisk. Das ist nicht Asterix, sondern Asterisk.
Wie der Stern auf der Telefontastatur.
Genau. Und der häufig zu Vermittlungszwecken verwendet wird bei Telefonieanlagen. Da drücke ich meinen Stern und kann ihn dann weiter verbinden z.B. Und dieses Asterisk integriert jetzt zu einer Telefonanlage mit Internet über Telefonie. Das heißt, ich schließe da mein ISDN-Telefon an, dann kann ich über das ISDN-Telefon sowohl ganz normal telefonieren im Telefonienetz, als auch in Anrufe über das Internet tätigen.
Und dann kann ich meine Freundin, die irgendwie in Amerika sitzt, ruf ich dann über Voice-Over-IP an und zahle dann gar kein Geld. Das ist also wirklich interessant, auch für einen Anwender.
Also zumindest kein Geld, das du nicht eh bezahlen musst für deinen Internetanschluss.
In dem Sinne, genau.
Genau, richtig. Da gibt es also unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten. Zum einen kann ich das mit so einer Vermittlungssoftware und echten Telefonen machen. Zum anderen gibt es Telefone, die das schon unterstützen. Ich kann mir einfach ein sogenanntes SIP, S-I-P, das ist eines der Voice-over IP-Protokolle, SIP, steht für Session Initiation Protocol, kaufen.
Das aktuelle Buzzword sozusagen.
Genau, das aktuelle Buzzword. Ein bisschen ältere Telefone unterstützen so den mehr oder weniger Vorgängerstandard H323. Und diese Telefone haben dann in aller Regel eine Ethernet-Steckdose. Das ist ein ganz normaler Netzwerkstecker. Das kann ich dann mit meinem DSL-Modem verbinden und dann eben direkt von dem Telefon in gewohnter Art und Weise Hörer abnehmen, Nummer wählen, Telefon nehmen.
Du hast das so ein Teil, oder?
Ich hab das seit mehreren Monaten, läuft das bei mir. Und seit ich diesen Obscure Netgear Router gegen einen Linksys ausgetauscht habe, funktioniert es auch richtig problemlos.
Wann hast du denn das gemacht?
In der vorletzten Radiosendung oder wie? Ne, wann war denn das?
Tja, weiß gar nicht. Also das ist auf jeden Fall eines der großen Probleme, die die Leute treffen. Zip und not traversal, wie sich das so schön nennt.
Da kommen wir dann noch separat dazu. Das sind dann die Probleme. Jetzt sprechen wir erstmal über die Möglichkeiten, die sich auftreten. Probleme handeln wir zum Schluss.
Was man hier klar machen soll, also dieses über Internet telefonieren, das ist insofern natürlich verwirrend, als dass, wenn man mit jemandem telefonieren möchte, dann möchte man natürlich eigentlich auch auf seinem Telefon anrufen. Also es gibt ja neben dem Internet nach wie vor das riesige Telefonnetz. Und es geht ja nicht nur darum, eine alternative Anschlussmethode zu finden, auf der einen Seite. Das heißt, entweder ich lass mir meinen ISDN-Anschluss nach Hause legen, und dann schließ ich mein ISDN-Telefon da an, oder ich hab einfach, ich sag einfach, ich hab Internet, ich brauch nicht noch eine Leitung, und mache die Verbindung über das Internet zu jemandem, der für mich diese Daten dann in das ISDN-Netz, oder Telefonnetz über welchen Zugang auch immer übermittelt. Das ist das, was diese SIP-Provider machen, von denen es jetzt schon einige gibt.
Das ist ein mögliches Anwendungsszenario.
Genau.
Also ich kann zum einen von einem Internetanschluss zu einem Internetanschluss telefonieren, ich kann aber auch von einem Internetanschluss in das normale Telefonnetz oder umgekehrt machen. Und dafür gibt es eben die sogenannten SIP- oder allgemein Voice-over-IP-Provider, die dann so ein Gateway über eine Vermittlungsstelle zwischen dem traditionellen Telefonnetz und dem Internet anbieten. Da bekomme ich dann eine Nummer und unter dieser Nummer können Leute anrufen und das wird dann dort gewandelt und über das Internet zu mir transportiert.
Mittlerweile sind wir tatsächlich beim Telefonieren, also normales Telefonieren, übers Internet angelangt. Und wir hätten natürlich gerne ein paar Klangbeispiele von euch. Also falls ihr Internet-Telefonie betreibt, ruft uns an unter 0331 70 97 110, auf das wir hier mal hören können, wie es sich anhört, wenn übers Internet telefoniert wird. Wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten. Danach sag ich dann nochmal, dass ihr bitte anrufen soll, weil Matthias muss Nachrichten machen, kann nicht ans Telefon gehen gleichzeitig.
Wenn Fritz in der Friednis, dann 103, 1.
Halb 12 genannt.
Die Nacht bleibt trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen auf Werte zwischen 14 und 8 Grad zurück. Morgen wird es richtig schön viel Sonne, ganz selten mal ein paar Quellwolken und kein Regen. Die Temperaturen klettern auf maximal 28 Grad und die Meldungen klettern auf Matthias Kerkov.
Zwei pakistanische Geiseln sind von ihren irakischen Entführern offenbar immordet worden. Das meldet der arabische Sender Al-Jazeera. Auf einem zugesandten Videoband seien ihre Leichen zu sehen gewesen. Die beiden Männer arbeiteten für den amerikanischen Streitkraftsdienst. Sie seien getötet worden, weil Pakistan Truppen in den Irak schicken wollte, hieß es auf dem Video. Die Bundesregierung will für mehr Wettbewerb und Transparenz auf dem Strom- und Gasmarkt sorgen. Dafür verabschiedete das Bundeskabinett den Entwurf für ein neues Energiewirtschaftsgesetz. Das Gesetz zieht eine Überwachung des Wettbewerbs durch eine Regierungsbehörde vor. Durch das neue Gesetz soll auch die Strompreismarktentwicklung sinken, heißt es. Der Prozess gegen den früheren Verteidigung Staatssekretär Holger Pfalz kann möglicherweise bereits im September beginnen. Pfalz stimmte heute einer raschen Auslieferung nach Deutschland zu. Pfalz war vor zwei Wochen in Paris gefasst worden. Der FC Bayern München steht im Finale des Liga-Pokals. Der deutsche Fußball-Rekordmeister gewann in Wattenscheid mit 3 zu 0 gegen Bayer Leverkusen. Der Gegner wird morgen zwischen dem Meister Werder Bremen und dem VfB Stuttgart ermittelt. Der Verkehr auf Fritz mit einer Meldung von der A2, Berliner Ring Richtung Magdeburg zwischen Wollin und César. Wieder einmal ein Unfall, zwei Fahrstreifen blockiert. Stau, bitte Vorsicht.
Zwei Minuten nach halb zwölf. Vielen Dank, Matthias.
Zwölf Jahre Blackboard Jungle. Die Fritzparty im To Be Club Berlin. Das exklusive Radiokonzert im großen Sendesaal des RBB. Virginia Jetzt. Live auch in der Wohlheide Berlin. Das Open Air auf dem ehemaligen Militärflugplatz Niedergörsdorf. Fritz, immer August. Blackboard Jungle, Scala, Seed, Virginia Jetzt und Summer Spirit. Tu alles zusammen, dann heißt das Preise Musik. Und im Radio Fritz.
Hey, du kannst doch die Musik nicht einfach ausmachen. Wir waren gerade so schön am Raven.
Ich mach die Musik nicht aus, du machst die Musik aus.
Ich hab die Musik doch nicht aus, aber du hast die Musik ausgemacht. Jetzt hast du sie wieder angemacht.
Die Musik hat dich selbst ausgemacht. Das ist halt ein sogenanntes grünes Album. So etwas hat tausend, ich kann natürlich hier auch gleich noch mal ein reiviges DJ-Set einspielen.
Ein reiviges DJ-Set einspielen, genau. Chaosradio 94, ihr seid aufgefordert anzurufen.
3-3-1 für Potsdam, 70-97-110.
Wir wollen mal einen kleinen Verbindungsqualität-Test machen. Also wenn ihr Internet-Telefonie betreibt oder zu Hause habt, ruft uns an und demonstriert uns hier im Radio und allen, die Radio hören, wie sich das anhört, wenn mit Internet telefoniert wird.
Ja, das ist übrigens relativ gut.
Also ich bin begeistert.
Meine Mutter sagt immer, also ich merke davon gar nichts, bis dann die Leitung zusammen bricht, aber das passiert dann doch ab und zu.
Also man sollte nebenbei irgendwie seine BitTorrent-Server vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen runtershapen und nicht so viel erzeugen, aber der Bandbreitenbedarf ist relativ gering, zumindest im Vergleich zu dem, was man heute eben so kriegt mit DSL 80k pro Richtung ist bei meinem.
Das ist schon äußerst viel eigentlich.
Äußerst viel.
Wie viele Hörer verschrecken wir, wenn wir kurz auf Bandbreite versus Latenz eingehen?
Verschrecken wir keine Hörer, da wollte ich unbedingt drauf eingehen.
Warte mal gerade, wir haben einen Anrufer, der Attila, hallo Attila. Womit telefonierst du gerade mit uns?
Ja mit IP-Fonien über Subgate.
Was für einem Telefon?
Das ist jetzt hier Softclient, das heißt PC, WLAN geroutet und dann auch noch mit ein Bluetooth Headset, also voll digital.
Ok, aber du plapperst im Prinzip direkt in deinen Laptop rein.
Genau.
Und welche Software benutzt du?
Xlight.
Ahja, auf? Was für einem Betriebssystem?
Und da Windows.
Und funktioniert das gut?
Also, ich bin richtig zufrieden, also ich bin telekomfrei mittlerweile zu Hause.
Aha, das heißt du hast deinen DSDN oder welchen Anschluss du auch immer vorgehabt hast abgestellt?
Genau, jetzt sind auch QSC und DSL und dann halt Internettelefonie.
Bist du dann auch immer zuverlässig anrufbar, also funktioniert das?
Bisher noch keine großen Probleme gehabt.
Tatsächlich, also weil ich habe so jeder dritte, vierte Anruf resultiert darin, dass ich nicht höre, wer am anderen Ende ist. Und ich am anderen Ende auch nicht höre, wer es klingelt, ich hebe ab. Also ich habe im Gegensatz zu der Atella ein richtiges Telefon an meinem Router hängen, dass das SIP kann und ich hebe ab und nichts passiert.
Da sollte man dann auch noch mal darauf eingehen. Es ist nämlich so, dass bei diesen Internettelefonie-Protokollen, insbesondere bei SIP, die Information über den Verbindungsaufbau und das Wählen und das Klingen, diese sogenannte Session-Information oder das Signaling-Information, die wird getrennt übertragen von den eigentlichen Audiodaten. Es kann durchaus sein, dass zwar die Signalisierung, also das Klingen deines Telefons, das Abheben usw. funktioniert, aber dann diese eigentliche Audioverbindung für das Übertragen der Sprachdaten in eine oder beide Richtungen nicht zustande kommt.
Ich habe einfach den Client quasi als DMZ-Host eingetragen und gesagt, alle Pakete, die du nicht kennst, bitte an den IP-Telefon Client übertragen. Dadurch geht das dann halt mit der Reichbarkeit.
Aber selbst als DMZ hat es bei mir mal nicht funktioniert.
Wir sollten DMZ erklären, das ist die Militarisierte Zone. Also ein Rechner, der quasi noch vor der Firewall des Routers steht und von daher sehr viel freizügiger mit dem Netz kommunizieren kann als ein Rechner dahinter. Und hast du es denn auch mal probiert, hinter, also außerhalb deiner DMZ das zu tun?
Ja, da hatte ich dann genau die gleichen Probleme mit Leuten, die auflegen, weil sie denken, ich möchte nicht mit denen sprechen und so. Also es funktioniert noch nicht wirklich hundertprozentig zuverlässig, zumindest mit dem SIP Client.
Was für ein Router benutzt du da?
Jetzt habe ich hier so einen SMC WLAN Router, Erricade. Wobei der das einigermaßen zuverlässig macht. Ich hatte vorher einen D-Link, mit dem wollte das nicht gehen. Also es ist schon etwas kompliziert. Mit dem alten, alt packenden Protokoll H323, was zum Beispiel die QSC für ihr IP-Telefonieprodukt benutzt, hat das aber bisher problemlos funktioniert. Also irgendwie scheint das alte Protokoll da ein bisschen besser zu sein.
Aber der Standard-Sprächern und SIP. Ja, also vielleicht mal zu der ganzen Historie und was es dafür Protokoll gibt und wo der Unterschied ist. Das H323 ist ein Protokoll, was von der ITU, von dieser International Telecommunications Union, also dieser Telefoniebehörde, mit den großen Messeständen spezifiziert wurde. Und das ist sozusagen Telefonie aus der Sicht der Telefonnetzbetreiber über das Internet übertragen.
Ja, wenn der Standard als Papier bestellen würde, dann kommt ein Lastwagen.
Ja, richtig, also das ist ein ganzer Standard. Da geht es also um H323, H225, H245, H2250, Q931, G711 und so weiter. Also das sind ganz tolle, viele Standards, die miteinander interoperieren. Und das bildet sozusagen das Telefonienetz über das Internet ab. Das ist ein Stückchen älter. Im Internet werden die Standards aber in die Regel durch die sogenannte IETF, durch die Internet Engineering Task Force, gesetzt. Und die hat dann eben in der sogenannten RFC 2543 dieses SIP, das Session Initiation Protocol, spezifiziert. Und das ist jetzt Internettelefonie aus der Sicht der Internettechniker. Das heißt, das sieht alles etwas sauberer aus und sieht eher so aus, wie im Internet üblicherweise die Protokolle aussehen. Und nicht so komische Bit-orientierte ASN 1-encodete Telefonieprotokolle.
Wenn ich jetzt mal ein bisschen lessern darf, haben die, die das Protokoll entworfen haben, aber noch nicht zur Kenntnis genommen, dass außer ihnen, die echte IP-Adressen haben, die ganze andere Welt hinter einem NAT, also Network Address Translation, sitzt. Und dass Protokolle, die nicht explizit NAT-freundlich sind, da große Probleme haben.
Ja, das sind aber beide in gleichem Maße. Also H323 hat genauso NAT-Probleme wie SIP. Das liegt einfach im Generellen daran, dass das nicht eine einzige Verbindung im Internet gemacht wird, also eine einzige TCP oder UDP-Verbindung, sondern dass hier in der Regel mehrere dazu benötigt werden und die in unterschiedliche Richtungen aufgebaut werden und dass da diese Geräte, die man daheim üblicherweise hat und als Router bezeichnet, die ja mit Wirklichkeiten NAT machen, Network Address Translation Probleme verursachen. Es ist nur so, dass H323 einfach schon länger existiert und dass man für H323 dann explizite Hilfssoftware in diesen Routern schon eingebaut hat. Das geht für SIP theoretisch auch, aber so weit ist die Technik da halt an dem Stand noch nicht. Da wird man einfach ein Stück Zeit noch warten müssen.
Ja, mit IPv6 und Ähnung wird alles besser dann bekommen.
Das ist wohl eher eine theoretische, sehr visionäre Option für in zehn Jahren.
Bei 1 zu 10 Jahren?
Na ja, vielleicht auch 5, aber das wird schon noch lang dauern. Und vor allem hilft das dem Problem auch nicht wirklich wahnsinnig weiter, weil diese Probleme, die existieren bei diesen komplexen Protokollen wie SIP und H323, die fangen eigentlich schon beim Paket Filter an, also bei der Firewall. Da muss noch gar nicht mal eine Adressumsetzung gemacht werden, sondern auch die Firewall muss diese Protokolle kennen, um die sicher herausfiltern zu können aus all dem, was da so ankommt vom Internet. Was all diese Internet-Telefonie für ein Problem hat, ist die sogenannte Latenzzeit, also die Zeit, wann ich etwas hineinspreche in meinen Telefon, bis das Amhörer auf der anderen Seite herauskommt. Weil das Internet einfach keine Garantien hat, was diese Zeit, diese sogenannte Latenzzeit betrifft. Es hängt einfach immer davon ab, wie stark das Netz belastet ist und über welche Strecke im Netz jetzt gerade meine Datenpakete transportiert werden. Also in aller Regel wird man bei Internettelefonie eine geringere Qualität haben, im Durchschnitt als das beim normalen Telefonienetz der Fall ist und leichte bis starke Verzögerungen feststellen, bis jetzt tatsächlich was am anderen Ende ankommt.
Der Attila ist noch bei uns am Telefon beziehungsweise am Internet. Ah geil, der Attila ist am Internet.
Schick mal ein paar Pakete.
Genau, ja mach ich mal.
Erzähl doch mal, wie das funktioniert. Also wie wird das abgerechnet? Weil du musst ja, wenn du raustelefonieren willst aus dem Internet auf einen normalen Telefonanschluss auch bezahlen.
Genau, das ist so ein Art Pre-Pay-Verfahren. Jetzt bei dem Anbieter, den ich zurzeit nutze, halt Zipgates, da buchen die einfach im Voraus so 10 Euro ab und die kann ich dann abtelefonieren. Haben vernünftige Gebühren eigentlich, die liegen unter den normalen Telekom-Gebühren, über den günstigsten Call-by-Call-Gebühren und das passt dann. Ein anderer Anbieter, mein eigener DSL-Anbieter, die QSC, die bietet das ganz normal per Rechnung halt auch an. Dann telefoniere ich und kriege dann am Ende die Monatsrechnung für DSL und dann die Telefonie geht aus.
Hat QSC auch diese Hardware-Lösung, also dass ich tatsächlich einen echten Telefonapparat in meinen Router stecke?
Die unterstützen eher die Freak-Lösungen nur mit dem PC, wo man dann immer noch an der Kette sitzt.
Selbstverständlich, also du kannst auch ein SIP-Telefon oder in dem Fall ein H323-Telefon verwenden, um zu telefonieren mit dem. Du kannst jetzt kein ganz normales, altes, analog-Telefon anschließen, aber...
Aber es ist dann eben nicht so komfortabel, weil ich hab zuhause eben auch SIP-Gate und das war so schön komfortabel, dass ich es einfach einstecke und es konfiguriert sich eben selbst. Das heißt, ich müsste bei QSC, wenn ich das benutzen wollte, dann händisch mich dadurch hangeln, wahrscheinlich durchs Telefon.
Attila, was du natürlich auch machen könntest, ich greife jetzt hier schon wieder vor, du könntest dir natürlich auch eine kleine Asterisk-Telefonanlage hinstellen, dann könntest du auch mit einem normalen Telefon telefonieren. Aber was mich eigentlich mal interessieren würde, ist, wie bist du drauf gekommen, das jetzt wirklich so zu betreiben, dass du jetzt telekomfrei bist?
Das war letzten Endes so ein Thema Optimierung meiner Telefonkosten. Ich zahle halt für bestimmte Dinge, die ich nicht immer nutze, extra. Ich bin relativ mobil, habe damals festgestellt, ich telefoniere viel auf dem Handy, ab und zu ins Ausland. Dafür lohnt sich dann mal die Telekom-Grundgebühr nicht. Dann habe ich nach einem DSL-Anbieter gesucht, weil netzabhängig bin ich dann schon. Da kommt man heutzutage nicht mehr drum hin. Dann habe ich nach einem Anbieter gesucht, der mir nur DSL verkauft ohne einen Telefonanschluss, weil ich gedacht habe, ich kann auch über Handy eigentlich günstig telefonieren. Dann habe ich festgestellt, dass dann ein paar Anbieter, wie unter anderem die QSC, das anbieten. Dann kam dann letzten Herbst die IP-Telefonie für Privatkunden auf. Das war dann interessant nach den ersten frühen Versuchen, die es sogar gab damals mit Net-Meeting, noch genau mit dem besagten ZIXL 1496 und was so klang, als hätte man eine Direktverbindung zu mir dabei. Es ist nur der Nachbar mit dem gleichen Modem nebenan gewesen. Das ist dann doch schon ein großer Fortschritt gewesen, als ich dann gehört hatte. Merken die Leute nicht, dass es ein Unterschied ist? Das Einzige, was ein Unterschied jetzt irgendwie war, was sie gemerkt haben, ist, dass ich ein Düsseldorfer Telefonum hatte, was für mich als Kirsener natürlich eine große Nachteil bedeutet.
Die ersten vier Wochen hatte ich auch ein Hamburger Telefonum, was auch immer schön war, wo ich dann zwei Stunden vor der Sendung unseren Aufnahmleiter angerufen habe. Und der hat gesagt, großer Gott, was machst du in Hamburg? Du musst doch nachher hier hin. Das war eigentlich ganz schön.
Kann man auch zum Vorteil verwenden. Ich habe zum Beispiel neben meinem normalen Berliner ISDN-Telefonanschluss habe ich einen Zipgate-Account mit einer Nürnberger Vorwahl. Ich komme ja aus dieser Ecke, wie man in der Sprache unschwer hört. Wenn mich Leute aus Nürnberg anrufen wollen, dann rufen die bei dieser Nürnberger Telefonnummer an, zahlen Ortsnetzgebühren und ich habe es dann letztendlich auf meinem Cisco IP-Telefon in Berlin.
Attila, warum hast du... Ich war in Tirol im Urlaub, im österreichischen Teil. Ich habe mich dann dort bei dem Hotel per WLAN ins Netz eingeklinkt und dann über Zipgate in Deutschland telefoniert und war dann zu Ortsnetzgebühren ohne Roamingkosten oder was auch immer dort erreichbar. Also das war...
Aber warum, Attila, hast du denn überhaupt eine Düsseldorfer Vorwahl, wenn du in Köln wohnst? Sie bieten doch auch Kölner Vorwahlen an oder nicht?
Und da muss man die neu kommunizieren. Und da ja meine Roots eigentlich auch im Fritz-Sendegebiet liegen, so in Berlin, Brandenburg, ist es egal, ob die jetzt nur in Köln oder Düsseldorf anrufen. Festnetz ist Festnetz. Und dann habe ich gesagt, dann bleibe ich bei der Düsseldorfer Rufnummer erst mal. Danke.
Chaosradio 94, wir sind auf der Suche nach Leuten, die per Internet telefonieren und die wir anrufen wollen, um zu demonstrieren, wie denn die Verbindungsqualität auch ist. Zipgate haben wir eben gehört, also von der Zipgate-Verbindung aus Köln mit einer Düsseldorfer Vorwahl, die hier angekommen ist. Was gibt's noch? Was hatten wir? Nikotel gab's noch?
Richtig, es gibt einige Anbieter. Freenet bietet das auch an. QSC hatten wir ja auch schon in Verbindung mit dem QSC DSL-Anschluss.
Skype mittlerweile auch. Also Skype wählt mittlerweile auch raus aus dem Internet.
Ja, vielleicht zu Skype noch eine Anmerkung. Das ist also ein Voice-over-IP-Dienst, der keines der standardisierten Protokolle verwendet, sondern die verwenden ein eigenes. Das heißt, man kann jetzt nicht von einem Reihen über das Internet, von einem Skype-Anschluss zu einem QSC-SIP-Anschluss z.B. telefonieren.
Das heißt, er müsste außen rum gehen praktisch und meinen SIP-Anschluss als normale Telefonnummer anrufen, obwohl er im Internet anruft.
Richtig, dann ruft jemand sozusagen von seinem Skype-Internet-Anschluss über das Telefonienetz zu deinem SIP-Provider und dort wird es dann wieder ins Internet gewandelt und das geht wieder über dich. Das ist dann die Quadratur des Kreises. Warum? Das müsste man wohl die Firmen fragen. Das Internet funktioniert einfach deshalb, weil es freie und offen dokumentierte Standards gibt. Es gibt immer wieder Firmen, die das noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben. Und man wird sehen, was sich dann letztendlich durchsetzt.
Die versuchen da, glaube ich, auch so einen Hype zu erzeugen und sich da einfach als Marke zu präsentieren. Das hat man ja häufig gesehen, auch beim Instant Messaging. Erst mal irgendwie alle versuchen, das rauszuholen, was da ist. Dann hat man erst mal einen Namen, der ist natürlich auch schon mal was wert, weil es halt hipper ist, irgendwie, was weiß ich, cooler aussieht, irgendwie so ein Special Feature hat, was man eben mit den Standards nicht machen kann. Und in der Folge verheiratet man es dann eh wieder mit den Standards, was man von vornherein weiß. Aber es ist dann eben irgendwie wer.
Und dann kostet es wahrscheinlich auch Geld. Skype sagt ja immer nur, die Beta wäre kostenlos.
Ja, die machen das sicherlich nicht, um kein Geld zu verdienen. Das kann man sich kaum vorstellen.
Nicht bei der Vorgehensweise.
Was auch nochmal wichtig ist zu erwähnen, ist, dass wenn ich rein vom Internet zu einem anderen Anschluss im Internet telefonieren will, also brauche ich keinen Anbieter und ich brauche keinen Account, ich brauche kein Guthaben und ich muss nichts zahlen. Es geht einfach über das Internet. Sobald ich einen Internetanschluss habe, funktioniert das. Nur dann, wenn ich diese Brücke in das traditionelle Telefonnetz schlagen möchte, dann muss ich hier in irgendeiner Art und Weise mir einen Anbieter suchen.
0331 77 97 110. Wer telefoniert denn über das Internet? Und würde jetzt gerne mal hier vorführen, wie sich das anhört. Also Freenet übrigens gibt es auch noch, die es anbieten. Und wenn man von den DSL Anschluss nimmt, dann gibt es glaube ich irgendwie auch noch frei Minuten für Umme. Also um ins klassische Telefonnetz zu telefonieren, wenn man draußen ist. Chaos Radio 94 telefoniert über das Internet.
Hast du auch so ein Telefon noch dazugeholt?
Äh, nee. Aber ich plane das mal zu machen. Ich wollte jetzt erst mal ausprobieren, wie es so klappt. Um dann, wie mein Vorredner, auch mal komplett umzusteigen. Aber nur wenn die Stabilität annimmbar ist.
Was für einen Internetanschluss benutzt du?
Öhm, über GameX.
Was ist das so kapazitätsmäßig?
Wie meinst du das?
Na, wie schnell? Ja, aber wie schnell? Da gibt es ja verschiedene. Also quasi im Upload, also zu uns nur 128 Kilobit, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, genau.
Okay, und hast du dann irgendwie Probleme mit dem Telefonieren, wenn du den Bein noch ein bisschen rumsuft?
Ähm, ja klar, da sollte ich die Füße stillhalten.
Ja, das heißt, es bricht dann schon ab und so. Also es gibt dann irgendwie Ruckler oder wie?
Was wäre das Letzte?
Ja, genau, deshalb wollte ich es mal noch ausprobieren und dann auch mal gucken, ob ich mir so eine Box hole, um ein richtiges Telefon anzuschließen.
Das finde ich ja auch ganz spannend, weil diese Box reserviert sich auch die Bandbreite, also sie kommt vor den Router nochmal. Ist selbst ein Router wohl, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Und reserviert sich die Bandbreite, die das Telefon auf jeden Fall zum Telefonieren braucht. Also die wird vorher abgezwackt, bevor du überhaupt dein Internet bekommst.
Man kann sowas auch im Router machen. Also wenn man jetzt nicht so ein Endprodukt kauft, das von den Funktionen her sehr beschränkt ist, sondern wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mit seinem eigenen Linux-Rechner einen Router betreibt, dann kann man durchaus mit sogenannten Traffic-Shaping-Maßnahmen oder auch Quality-of-Service ist das Schlagwort dazu, hier Bandbreiten sowohl fest reservieren, als auch einfach bevorzugen.
Ich kann das nicht, also...
Ja, ich sag ja, wenn man...
Ja, der Woman-Acceptance-Factor sollte doch da sein. Das heißt, wenn die Frau im Hause das nicht akzeptiert, dann brauchen wir das nicht anschaffen.
Ich kenne das nur als Spouse-Approval-Factor. Was, was, was? Sag mal, wie telefonierst du denn jetzt einfach? Hast du ein Headset oder hast du ein Mikrofon und Lautsprecher? Ich habe ein Headset auf. Das ist ja dann auch gewöhnungsbedürftig. Also wenn man jetzt länger telefoniert, ist das wahnsinnig angenehm, aber wenn man einfach nur mal kurz anrufen will, dann nervt das ja. Das bringt dann einen dann wahrscheinlich dazu, sich tatsächlich so ein richtiges normales Telefon-Endgerät anzuschaffen.
Das ist ja auch ein bisschen, also ich merke halt auch mal wieder, man kommt sich schon ein bisschen doof vor, weil man irgendwie immer so einen 20 Zentimeter Abstand vor seinem Laptop kniet, und dann irgendwie so auf die Tastatur redet, so als hätte man so eine persönliche Beziehung zu F1. Insbesondere, wenn auch andere Leute...
Man ist normal halt ein Deck-Telefon gewohnt.
Also es gibt, die Technik steht ja da erst am Anfang, aber es gibt mittlerweile durchaus zum einen die Möglichkeit, dass man eben so eine Telefonanlage betreibt, die dann ein analoges Telefon oder ein Deck, also so ein schnurloses Telefon anbindet an das Voice-over-IP. Oder aber es gibt mittlerweile auch Telefone, die über dieses Wireless-LAN, also über dieses 802.11 oder WLAN oder wie auch immer es genannt wird, über diesen Standard für Funknetzwerke kommunizieren. Die sind noch sehr teuer und die Akkulaufzeit ist sehr gering usw. Aber das sind alles technische Probleme, die in Kürze gelöst werden.
Aber woran du jetzt im Moment konkret denkst, dass ist so eine kleine Box, die schließt du an dein Internet an, auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite an dein Telefon.
Richtig?
Ja, genau.
Und die gibt es glaube ich auch für relativ wenig Geld. Was kostet die 40 Euro? Mehr als 100 Euro.
Nee, ein Honi ist das schon.
Honi kosten die noch?
Ja, je nachdem wo du kaufst. Du kannst versuchen, es in den USA zu kriegen, somit irgendwie selber reinfliegen, dann ist wohl eher die Hälfte. Aber hier wird derzeit noch der Early Adopters Punishment Fee auch geschlagen. Die ist ja, wie wir wissen, nicht ganz unerheblich. Also ich finde, wo wir das gerade angesprochen haben, mit diesem sozialen Verhalten, kann mich noch gut erinnern, Anfang der 90er Jahre, als man im Prinzip für angeschaut wurde wie so ein Triebtäter, wenn man irgendwie sein Telefon, also sein Mobiltelefon benutzt hat und sich auf einmal so ein schwarzes Briket an die Backe geklebt hat, dann fanden die Leute einen ja schon sehr unhöflich. Jetzt gibt es dieses neue Phänomen, das erlebt man in der Uni, dass irgendwelche Studenten auf einmal anfangen, so mit ihrem Laptop zu reden. Eben hat man sich noch unterhalten und dann haben sie irgendwie ihren Freund in Kanada angeklickt. Hat man ja auch noch nicht erwähnt, mit Instant-Messaging und Telefonie. Das funktioniert ja eigentlich mittlerweile auch ganz gut. Also wirklich so ein neues Phänomen. Und ich denke, dass auch die Bluetooth-Headsets da demnächst eine Rolle spielen, wenn sie mal richtig funktionieren, wovon man jetzt halt noch nicht so richtig berichten kann.
Also deins hat doch kürzlich noch funktioniert.
Ja, kürzlich hat es funktioniert, aber es hat dann auch sehr kürzlich, es ist ablehmig geworden und es hat einfach so aufgehört zu sein. Das ist schon alles ziemlich dramatisch.
Bernhard? Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf, bevor wir hier völlig abschweifen und dich vergessen. Chaosradio 94, wir telefonieren mit Computern ist unser Thema heute Abend.
Das war der Mann mit der Latenz.
Der Mann mit der Latenz. Wir haben noch einen Anrufer, 0331-70-97-1-0, die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline und Marco ist dran. Hallo Marco. Du hast eine Frage.
Ich höre ja eine sicherheitstechnische Frage, wie schwer oder leicht wäre es für jemanden, irgendwas zu programmieren, so wie derzeit vielleicht irgendwelche Dialer gibt, die dann dieses IP-Telefonie irgendwie ansprechen, damit das loswählt und dann zum Beispiel auch irgendeine teure Nummer anwählt. Dann hätte man ja den Effekt, dass man über die DSL-Leitung halt irgendwas teures anruft.
Das geht natürlich relativ leicht, diese sogenannten Voice-over-IP-Provider, die geben dir einen Benutzernamen und ein Passwort und sobald irgendein Dialer oder was auch immer ein bösartiges Programm in Besitz dieser Daten kommt, kann das natürlich unter dem Benutzernamen und unter dem Passwort beliebige Nummern anrufen und Gebühren erzeugen.
Wie ist denn die Verschlüsselung bei SIP?
Bei SIP selbst muss da überhaupt gar keine Verschlüsselung da sein.
Nein, nicht wie das Passwort im Klartext, nicht im Ernst.
Das kommt, es ist ähnlich wie bei IMAP oder bei anderen Protokollen, es kann im Klartext übertragen werden, aber du kannst auch jetzt irgendwie einen MD5-Hash oder irgend so etwas machen für die technisch versierte, also so eine verschlüsselte Passwortübertragung. Das hängt aber davon ab, was der Provider unterstützt und was das Endgerät unterstützt und was die dann untereinander aushandeln. Theoretisch kann man noch viel mehr verschlüsseln bei SIP. Also es gibt auch einen Standard dafür, wie das komplette SIP-Protokoll verschlüsselt wird, dass also niemand mehr abhören könnte, mit wem jetzt telefoniert wird oder was da gerade ausgetauscht wird. In der Praxis kenne ich aber kaum Software, die das bislang implementiert.
Also bei SSL dann, SIP-S oder so, meinst du?
Nein, es gibt tatsächlich einen Standard in der IETF, der spezifiziert, wie SIP-Nachrichten in PgP eingefuckt werden, die eigentlich Klartextnachrichten sind.
Aber die Frage ist nach den Dylern und da sieht die Lage ganz genauso aus.
Richtig, das bringt einem in dem Fall nichts weiter.
Bevor man sozusagen lostelefoniert, hebt man ab und dann tippt man irgendwie seinen Benutzer oder Name und Kennwort ein.
Üblicherweise legt natürlich die Software das irgendwo ab und da ist ein interessantes Bienenest angestochen. Das kennt man ja schon, Passwörter, die auf der Platte abgelegt sind, sind ein Problem. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie die erstbeste Tohobabu Telefonie-Software benutzt, die irgendwie so klug ist, das Ding im Klartext in deinen Voreinstellungen irgendwo gut sichtbar für jedes Software abzulegen, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass irgendeine wild gewordene Software das auch herausbekommen kann. Und zwar sehr einfach, also an der Stelle wird es schwierig. So wie Viren und Würmer heute problemlos dein Adressbook von Outlook oder sowas auslesen und dann eher Unwesen treiben und auch Dialer machen das natürlich ähnlich, ist das hier ganz genauso möglich und auch ein echtes Problem. Insofern wäre es überhaupt sinnvoll, als allererstes darauf zu achten, dass wenn man mit Software arbeitet auf seinem Computer, dass man dieses Kennwort, also dass man in irgendeiner Form sicherstellt oder zumindest soweit ich hinterfragt, dass man weiß wie es läuft, dass eben dieses Kennwort auch amtlich verschlüsselt abgelegt wird. Das geht halt entweder, also auf Mac zum Beispiel gibt es dieses System Keychain, wo ohnehin alle Programme ihr Passwort ablegen und dann ist es eben mit einer recht modernen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus verschlüsselt, diesem AES 256. Bei Windows muss ich passen, da weiß ich nicht ganz genau, ob es da überhaupt so etwas gibt wie ein Schlüsselbund.
Gibt es sowas? Ne, nicht im Betriebssystem selber, nicht dass ich wüsste, da macht jeder das, jede Applikation macht das für sich selber.
Genau, also da bist du sozusagen ein bisschen im Wald. Letzten Endes hast du aber auch mit dem Telefon dasselbe Problem, weil natürlich das Passwort muss natürlich irgendwo gespeichert sein, es ist dann eben im Zweifelsfall in dem Speicher in diesem Telefon drin.
Nur mein Telefon telefoniert nicht, wenn ich es nicht abgehoben habe.
Ja, aber dein Telefon reagiert unter Umständen auf Netzwerkanfragen, wenn du es nicht abgehoben hast, weil das ist ja ein Computer, da ist ja ein Web-Server drin, mit dem du das konfigurierst und von daher hat es einfach genau die gleiche Angriffsschlecher. Im Prinzip ist es auch wieder ein echtes Thema, die Sicherheit dieser Telefone zu machen. Wir können Stein und Bein draufschweren, dass das, was heutzutage so an SIP-Telefonen verkauft wird, einfach Löcher hat, wie Käse. Das ist vollkommen klar.
Von daher hat sich immer das Prepaid-Guthaben klein halten am besten.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Die Dialer funktionieren ja so, dass das Programm des Virus, der Wurm, ruft eine 190er-Rufnummer an oder eine Rufnummer in irgendeinem Land, wo es sehr teuer ist und bekommt davon Geld ab. Die Leute machen das ja, um Geld zu verdienen. Solange du gar kein Gateway benutzt, wie jetzt Niko-Tel oder Zipgate, und nur im Internet telefonierst, ist es vollkommen harmlos. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. In dem Moment, in dem du jetzt Zipgate benutzt und du hast ein Guthaben von 10 Euro, dann kann es dir natürlich passieren, sobald sich das genügend rumgesprochen hat, dass irgendjemand über den Dialer sozusagen eine 190er-Rufnummer anruft und dann deine 10 Euro in kürzester Zeit weg sind, da wie immer Kontrolle über die Rechnung. Ja, Dialer sind so ein bisschen auch ein Windows-Problem.
Sehr.
Also wäre zumindest eine etwas bessere Alternative ein echtes Hardware-Telefon.
Ist ein bisschen sichere, aber wenn dann tatsächlich das Passwort im Klartext übertragen wird, dann kann ein Rechner, der im gleichen Netzwerk angeschlossen ist, das schon auch sich mit Sniffen so genannt.
Genau, also das Wichtigste wäre überhaupt erst mal auf ein Telefonsystem, egal ob das Software oder Hardware ist, zu drängen, was verschlüsselt arbeitet und auch diese Telefon-Provider müssen einfach in Kürze alle nachlegen. Das wissen die sicherlich auch schon und wenn sie es nicht wissen, dann haben sie ein Problem, weil das natürlich gerade aus den genannten Gründen ein echtes Problem ist. Außerdem haben wir natürlich auch noch das andere Thema, abhören, ist natürlich im Internet einfach auch mal wieder schön einfach. Derzeit muss man Zugriff auf das Telefonnetz haben, das haben die Behörden natürlich, aber nicht gleich wie im Internet tausende von Providern, die man jedes Mal benutzt. Und man muss sich schon im Klaren sein, dass wenn man eben eine nicht verschlüsselte Verbindung hat, dass die dann eben auch von ihrem Audiotransfer her mitgehört werden kann.
Von sozusagen zufälligen Individuen mehr oder weniger.
Random Suspects.
Für die Behörden ist es außerordentlich schwierig geworden, Voice-over-IP-Telefonate abzuhören. Und da ist keine Infrastruktur für vorhanden soweit ich weiß.
Richtig, das wurde auch diskutiert, als die IETF dieses Session Initiation Protocol spezifiziert hat, da hat man explizit gesagt, wir uns interessieren diese Bedarfsträger nicht. Wir wollen keine extra Mechanismen für die sogenannte Lawful Interception einbauen in unsere Protocole und die sollen schauen, wo sie bleiben. Das ist eben anders bei dem H323, was ja aus dieser ITU herauskommt und die ITU, die die Erfahrungen aus dem Telefoniernetz heraus hat, die achtet immer sehr genau darauf, dass da Abhörschnittstellen und dergleichen eben mit eingebaut sind, dass Abhörmöglichkeiten überhaupt vorhanden sind.
Marco, alles klar? Dann eine gute Nacht noch. Wir haben hier noch was eventuell interessantes. Zwei Jans haben wir hier, ne? Ihr telefoniert womit?
Also wir haben Asterisk, beide. Der Jan ist in Aachen und das ist halt eine SIP-Verbindung zwischen mir hier in Potsdam und ihm in Aachen. Und euch rufen wir halt über ISDN an.
In der Konferenz?
Genau. Sehr schön.
Also nochmal, also nochmal. Wir sind jetzt, also dieses Studio ist jetzt per ganz normal ISDN, wie es jeder kennt, in deine Asterisk-Risk-Anlage gedingst.
Ja, genau. Also das ist der Router und der hat halt eine Fritz-Card für extern und für intern eine HFC-Card.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine ISDN-Card, die man quasi so als Amt betreiben kann und dadurch kann man halt ISDN-Telefone, zum Beispiel, ich hab hier eine Baze-Station für deckt angeschlossen, ziemlich günstig anschließen, weil die Karten richtig billig sind. Und man hat halt die ganzen Features von Asterisks dann zur Verfügung.
Welche wären das zum Beispiel?
Ich glaube, bei Conrad-Elektronik gibt es welche.
Features meine ich. Genau, was machst du damit?
Also ich hab ein Skript geschrieben, das sagt Least-Core-Shooting, checkt also im Internet den billigsten Tarif für die Telekom. Fürs Pre, ja, es ist Call-by-Call. Du hast Voice-Mail, also ziemlich professionelles Voice-Mail, kann auch per E-Mail die Sachen weiterleiten. Und naja, so Sachen wie Warte-Musik und so weiter. Und halt alle Protokolle, SIP, H323, das Cisco-Protokoll, dieses Genie, also ist alles dabei. Also es kann ja alles im Endeffekt.
Das ist quasi das Open Source Projekt, das man benutzen will.
Wer ist jetzt in Aachen? Bist du jetzt gerade in Aachen?
Telefonanlagen.
Hören wir dich jetzt gerade aus Aachen oder was? Alles klar, okay.
Und da er ja in Berlin wohnt, kann er halt billig per ESN raustelefonieren. Um die Zuverlässigkeit missen zu erhöhen. Ich meine, ich hab zwar QDSL und es ist halt auch Shaping mäßig überhaupt gar kein Problem. Wir hatten das hier halt auch schon komplett über VPN verschlüsselt am Laufen und seitdem QSP halt ihre Leitung ausgerüstet hat, ist es halt überhaupt gar kein Problem mehr, auch mit viel Downed Upstream da flüssig zu telefonieren. Also es ist halt echt überhaupt gar kein Problem mehr. Ich benutze es halt hier als Festnettersatzanschluss mit der SRP-Geld auch. Und muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es ist auch so viel billiger, dass diese 10 Euro, die ich da mal drauf überwiesen habe, einfach bis jetzt halten.
Das ist bei mir genauso. 30 Euro habe ich da mal hin überwiesen. Ich habe immer noch 27 oder so.
Obwohl, ich muss mal sagen, mit dem Lease-Kost-Tutor komme ich eigentlich immer mit 1 Cent oder so in Deutschland weg.
Ja, aber du hast noch eine ISDN-Grundgebühr, ne?
Ja, das stimmt, aber ich brauche ja mein TDSL. Hier gibt es ja kein QDSL.
Könnt ihr noch mal so sagen, was ihr in diesen Asterisk-Server so an Geld investiert habt? Also was das wirklich gekostet hat, so eine Telefonanlage aufzubauen, die jetzt über diese ganzen Features verfüllt?
Ja, also ich kann es ja mal überschlagen. Bei mir habe ich eine Fritz-Card, weißte nicht, was kostet die 30 Euro?
Fangen wir mal mit dem PC an.
Also die sind noch billiger inzwischen als die FC-Karten, glaube ich.
Fangen wir mal mit dem PC an, weil das ja die wichtigste Komponente.
Ja, und ich denke mal, die wird auf eBay so 15 bis 20 Euro kosten.
Ja, und PC haben wir hier so, also ich habe hier einen P2 300 und der ist halt völlig ausreichend dafür.
Also ein alter Pentium 2 oder Pentium 3 tut es auf jeden Fall.
Also das ist halt dadurch, dass man halt Hardware DSPs benutzt, das ist halt eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Problem. Also die Karten machen ja das ganze Wandeln und so, deswegen ist es sehr, sehr C2 spannend. Ich glaube, für dieses PBX-Verlienungs, dieses Konkurrenz-Projekt, in Anführungsstrichen von dem einen Menschen aus Köln, dem Jolly, der ja auch auf dem Kongress war und dort NCWAs verschenkt hat, die man braucht, quasi um das Strom in den lokalen S0-Bus einzuführen, weil natürlich aus der PC-Karte kein Strom für die Telefone rauskommt, da hat man angegeben, dass man so ein Tencent 200 MMX mindestens braucht. Und das ist halt irgendwie jetzt eigentlich so was, das man überall rumstehen hat.
Oder ganz billig irgendwo abstauben kann. Also so uralt PCs, die kosten kein Geld.
Ich denke mal, wenn man Glück hat, ist man vielleicht sogar mit 50 Euro insgesamt dabei.
Für die komplette Telefonanlage.
Ja, für die schon.
Und wie kompliziert war das Aufsetzen?
Ja, das war natürlich schon wieder eine andere Sache. Der Punkt ist, die Doku von Asterisk ist halt, weil es noch so stark in der Entwicklung ist. Rattenschlacht. Und es gibt da halt Wikis, wo das alles sehr gut zusammengetragen ist. Zum Beispiel das voip-info.org-wiki.
Gut, dass du das erwähnt hast. Das hätten wir eigentlich schon längst mal tun sollen.
Ich hab mal ins Wiki gepostet, auch den Link.
In die Wikipedia, in die Mitmachseite, die wir noch gar nicht erwähnt haben.
Ist auch nicht verlinkt von der Seite, deswegen muss ich erstmal durch irgendwelche Mail-Archive greppen.
Also mit anderen Worten, man kann irgendwie für 100 Euro sich eine Telefonanlage bauen, mit der man dann beliebig viele ISDN-Telefone intern betreiben kann, vorausgesetzt, man hat noch so ein paar NTBAs rumliegen.
Was sich halt ein bisschen beschränkt ist die Anzahl der Steckplätze. Also eigentlich kann ich hier sinnvoll in meinem Router nur einen internen S0 betreiben.
Und analoge Anschlusskarten?
Ja, das würde ich aber nicht empfehlen. Das sieht doch mal realistisch aus. So eine HFC-Karte, die ist viel billiger als analoge Karten.
Ja, aber die ISDN-Telefone sind teurer als die analogen. Ja, aber da hab ich ja noch so ein dummes Teil rumliegen.
Die funktionieren auch nicht gut. Das ISDN ist halt erst mal digital. Das heißt, du hast auch die Rufnummern-Anzeige, auf jeden Fall im Funktionieren, wo du bei irgendwelcher amerikanischen oder asiatischen Hardware nicht so sicher sein kannst. Und es wählt halt schneller und es ist einfach hübscher, finde ich.
Ja, ist klar. Aber wenn ich jetzt so ein altes Backeli-Telefon da anschließen möchte, so mein gutes altes T01, dann würde mir das ja reichen. Gibt es diese Karten denn bezahlbar?
Du meinst die analogen Karten? Ja. Ja, die kriegt man so in amerikanischen Shops. Es gibt wohl auch so Fakes von der Digium-Hardware, die man im Asterisk-Fall benutzen kann. Aber es ist trotzdem immer noch teurer, als wenn man sich so eine HFC-Karte kauft.
Wie viel ungefähr?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht 70 Dollar oder sowas.
Für wie viele Ports?
Für einen Port. Ja klar, es gibt halt auch Karten, die können dann mehr Ports, aber es gibt halt auch für die ganze digitale Technik wirklich dann Karten, die viel mehr Ports haben. Du kannst ja auch eine Premiere-Multiplex-Karte oder sowas in das Asterisk integrieren und das ist alles kein Problem.
Anlagenanschluss halt?
Also 30 ISDN-Kanäle. Man muss dazu sagen, dass diese sogenannten HFC-Karten, von denen gesprochen wurde, ich kenne den Großhandelspreis, den ich bekomme, der liegt bei 9 Euro irgendwas. Das ist so wahnsinnig billig, diese ISDN-Karten mittlerweile, dass man sich eigentlich gar keine Gedanken mehr darüber macht.
Da muss man halt nur noch ein ISDN-Telefon finden, was irgendwie hübsch ist.
Ja, also du musst halt auch ein bisschen basteln, das darfst du nicht vergessen. Du musst ja die Drähte gekreuzt an den NTBA anschließen und alles.
Das ist übrigens auf der Seite von diesem PBX-Vorlinus-Projekt beschrieben, falls das jemand interessiert.
Ja, das ist sehr nett beschrieben da.
Super, das ist istdn.jolly.de. Also J-O-L-L-Y.
Ja, aber ich denke es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Also ich bin ein glücklicherer Mensch geworden, seit ich diese Telefonanlage habe.
Das ist doch mal eine schöne Nachricht.
Also er ist besonders glücklich seitdem er als Wartemusik, weil also wenn er irgendwie wartet oder markiert, also Music on hold hat, hat er sich halt so ein Music MP3 eingespielt, was so Witze enthält und das sorgt für immer sehr gute Stimmung, wenn er dann anruft.
Man kann es sogar auch, weil er alles frei programmierbar ist, sowas machen wie dieses T-Ring-Cones oder wie auch immer das heißt, da wo man Musik hat, wenn man jemanden anruft und so. Das ist also richtig hübsch, man kann da jeden Tag spielen, wenn man will.
Nur, dass es dann halt schon kostet, wenn man irgendwie anruft.
Na gut, aber wenn man intern anruft, dann ist es halt ein nettes Gimmick.
Oder einfach nur übers Internet, also Kosten tut es ja immer nur, wenn du ins Telefonienetz willst.
Ja, naja, also meinte halt, wenn ich jetzt jemanden hier anrufe, in Potsdam zum Beispiel, über das normale Netz, und dann kann ich halt auch Musik einspielen lassen, wenn ich das jetzt gerade toll finde.
Also, Spiel doch mal richtig ein.
Ja, genau.
Finde das mal toll jetzt.
Ich glaube, das ist nur das Witz der MP3, ne? Nein, keine Ahnung. Ich wollte noch mal was sagen zu dem...
Du bist im großen Flur.
Ja, Sicherheit?
Sicherheit, und zwar das ist natürlich ein Problem mit der ganzen unverschlüsselten Geschichte. Natürlich hat man dann auch irgendwie teilweise eine Angst, dass man dieses doch noch recht junge Asterisk aus seiner Firewall aufmacht. Ja, und da man ja sowieso nur mit immer bestimmten Leuten telefoniert. Wir haben es halt also zuerst hier gehabt mit VPN und das hat auch sehr gut funktioniert. Also ich sage hat, weil es irgendwie dann genau auf meiner Not aufgehört hat, zu funktionieren, auf unaktionärlichen Gründen. Aber es hat zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es funktioniert hat, so gut funktioniert, dass wir uns echt gewundert haben, wie gut es funktionieren kann. Das halt dann voll kann, alles einfach über Vorfern zu laufen lassen. Und bei IAX halt zwischen den beiden Asterisk-Anlagen ist das ja auch kein Problem. SubGate setzt ja auch auf IAX bzw. auf Asterisk.
Ja, vielleicht an der Stelle für unsere Hörer. Was ist IAX?
IAX ist der Inter-Asterisk Exchange Protocol. Das ist quasi das, was man benutzen will, wenn man zwischen zwei Asterisk-Telefonanlagen telefoniert. Was kann denn das?
Ja, es ist also erstmal ein bisschen mehr Lightweight als SIT, so wie ich das verstanden habe. Das war wohl der Hintergrund, ein einfacheres Protokoll zu machen, was besser durch NAT durchkommt etc. Und es ist halt speziell auf die Art, wie Asterisk diesen Dialplan hat. Also welche Aktionen passieren, wenn man welche Nummern wählen, abgestimmt und keine Ahnung, was genau der Hintergrund war.
Weil ich habe gelesen, dass jetzt ZipG zum Beispiel auch vorhat, IAX direkt zu unterstützen. Was würde das für Vorteile bringen?
Also ich würde vor allem sehen, dass ich dann weniger Probleme mit eventuellem durch NAT durchkommen hätte.
Ja, ach, das kann man auch dazu sagen. Wenn man das machen will, dann will man das aus seinem Router machen, weil wenn man das erstmal durch so einen anderen Router durch NATen muss. Und ich hatte ja vorher so eine OpenBSD Firewall, die ja für ihre Firewall-Funktionalität gerühmt werden. Das ist irgendwie vollkommen irgendwie unmöglich gewesen, da schmerzfrei vorwärts zu kommen. Also es lohnt sich nicht aus, weil man ja mehrere Rechner laufen. Und also FIP ist echt mal und NAT, das sind so zwei Sachen, die bedeuten viele schlaflose Nächte.
Ja, und wenn ich da vielleicht mal einsteigen darf an diesem Punkt mit dem NAT, da gab es also schon die, ich soll sagen, man ist in der IETF bei der Standardisierung von SIP auf dieses Problem durchaus gestoßen. Hat dann eine eigene Working Group gegründet, die sich nur mit diesem Problem befasst und tut das jetzt glaube ich auch schon wieder seit drei Jahren oder vier. Nur leider ist dabei immer noch nichts Vernünftiges rausgekommen. Die einzige wirkliche Alternative oder die einzige wirkliche Möglichkeit ist eben zumindest einen SIP-Proxy, wenn nicht dann eben eine ganze Telefonanlage auf dem Router direkt laufen zu lassen, dann ist man die Probleme los.
Ich weiß, dass das Asterisk auf jeden Fall der Quatsch-GS-IP-Header re-writeen kann, um dieses Nuttproblem ein bisschen in den Griff zu kriegen. Ich habe ja auch ein Cisco-Telefon dahinter und das sollte das eigentlich lösen. Aber ich habe mich damit nicht weiter beschäftigt.
Ich habe auch ein Cisco-Telefon mit Asterisk gehalten.
Die Hoffnung ist halt, dass das V6 sich ein bisschen mehr durchsetzt und dass man Asterisks auch kann. Das ist halt irgendwie mal viel sinnvoller, wenn man das Endgerät dann direkt anwählen kann. Ich meine, gerade dieses Ich steck's dran und es funktioniert, dürfte mit IPv6 deutlich besser funktionieren.
Theoretisch zumindest, ja. Das große Problem wird sein. Aber das ist nun wirklich nicht Thema dieser Sendung, wie sich die Provider mit der Vergabe von IPv6-Prefixen verhalten. Das kann halt noch keiner sagen.
Darf ich noch mal kurz was zur Security sagen? Und zwar, diese ganze Datentraffic geht ja über RTP. Und ich hab jetzt neulich auch mal gesehen, dass es wohl bald vielleicht auch SRTP oder sowas gibt. Dass halt wirklich der Datenstrom an sich dann verschlüsselt wird. Das hat ja auch nichts. Dann braucht man nicht so ein VPN als den Todschläger und kann auch mit Leuten, mit denen man kein VPN pflegen möchte, dann Security telefonieren, da freu ich mich schon drauf.
Ja, das ist sicherlich eine sinnvolle Ergänzung.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Hattest du nicht auch vorhin gesagt, dass noch ein neues Level-4-Protokoll entwickelt wird, um diesem Problem ein bisschen härter zu werden?
Ja, die IETL arbeitet gerade an einem neuen Level-4-Protokoll. Level-4-Protokoll heißt, das ist sowas wie TCP oder UDP im normalen Internet jetzt. Das nennt sich dann DCCP. Und man versucht ja ein unglaubliches, leichtgewichtiges, wie man das im Amerikanischen sagt, ein Lightweight-Protokoll zu haben, das speziell für Audio-Streaming und Echtzeit-Multimedia-Anwendungen gedacht ist.
Das Datagramm-Congestion-Control-Protokoll.
Genau.
Und für die Leute, die sich jetzt wirklich auskennen, Sally Floyd schreibt mit an dem Standard. Also man darf davon ausgehen, dass da was Vernünftiges rauskommt. Hat aber jetzt mit der Sicherheit nichts zu tun, es ist einfach nur ein Protokoll, das speziell dafür optimiert ist, Echtzeit, Multimedia-Kommunikation im Netz zu realisieren.
Ja, das wollen sich doch die ganzen Gamer.
Ja, auch für die Gamer und für die Peer-to-Peer-Protokolle. Und wer im Moment eben alles UDP einsetzt, aber eigentlich gar kein UDP einsetzen will, für die Leute ist das gedacht. Ein Satz, den ich noch sagen wollte, oder ein Punkt, warum macht man das alles? Natürlich ist es toll, es ist cool, es ist neu, man kann damit spielen. Aber es gibt tatsächlich auch einen ganz wichtigen Grund, warum man IP-Telefonie verwenden sollte eigentlich. Und zwar ist das günstige Telefonieren über weite Entfernungen. Ich kann einfach, ich meine jetzt in Deutschland im Ortsnetzbereich, das würde ich vorhin schon erwähnen, man kann eigentlich, wenn man Least-Cost-Rooting betreibt, immer unter 1 Cent die Minute telefonieren. Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwo ins Ausland telefoniere, dann sehen die Preise doch ganz anders aus. Das Internet macht da natürlich keinen Unterschied. Also ich kann problemlos in die USA oder nach Brasilien telefonieren. Ist kein Problem. Und es gibt natürlich in den ganzen Ländern auch SIP-Anbieter, also SIP-Provider, die Gateways betreiben. Das heißt, ich kann mir jetzt in den USA ein Prepaid-Gut haben von 10 Dollar holen und kann das dann eben in den USA zu US-Festnetzpreisen abtelefonieren, hier von Deutschland aus. Oder ich kann mir sogar eine Flatrate holen, das heißt, ich kann dann innerhalb der USA für 19 Dollar im Monat so viel telefonieren, wie ich möchte, von meinem SIP-Anschluss hier in Deutschland. Vielleicht ein paar Anbieter dazu. Es gibt dann Broad Voice, das sind die mit der Flatrate. Es gibt Voice Pulse, bei denen sind eingehende Anrufe glaube ich sogar kostenlos. Und noch Free World Dial-up, da gibt es einige Anbieter, die hier zur Verfügung stehen.
Fritz in Neukölln, dann 102, 6.
Eine Folge, äh eins.
Fritz Info.
Die Nacht bleibt trocken, die Temperaturen gehen auf Werte zwischen 14 und 8 Grad zurück. Tagsüber wird es richtig schön, viel Sonne, kein Regen, Temperaturen maximal 28 Grad. Meldung jetzt mit Matthias Kerkov.
Zwei pakistanische Geiseln sind von ihren irakischen Entführern offenbar ermordet worden, das mediterrabische Sender Al-Jazeera. Die beiden Männer arbeiteten für die amerikanischen Streitkräfte. Sie seien getötet worden, weil Pakistan Truppen, in den Irak schicken wollte, berichtet ein Sender. Die Bundesregierung will für mehr Wettbewerb und Transparenz auf dem Strom- und Gasmarkt sorgen. Dafür verabschiedete das Bundeskabinett den Entwurf für ein neues Energiewirtschaftsgesetz. Das Gesetz sieht eine Überwachung des Wettbewerbs durch eine Regulierungsbehörde vor. Durch das neue Gesetz sollen auch die Strompreise sinken. Der Prozess gegen den früheren Verteidigungsstaatssekretär Holger Pfalz kann möglicherweise bereits im September beginnen. Pfalz stimmte heute einer raschen Auslieferung nach Deutschland zu. Er war vor zwei Wochen in Paris gefasst worden. Der FC Bayern München steht im Finale des Liga-Pokals. Der deutsche Fußball-Rekordmeister gewann in Wattenscheid mit 3 zu 0 gegen Bayer Leverkusen. Der Gegner wird morgen zwischen Meister Werder Bremen und dem VfB Stuttgart ermittelt. Der Verkehr Fritz hat nichts zu vermelden. Weiter gute Fahrt.
Halb eins genau.
Fritz, neunst euch die 90er. Fritz, bringt euch die 90er. Die drittsneunziger Party on the road. Und Titel, von dem ihr nicht mal mehr wisst, was ihr sie kanntet. Die Fritz-90er-Party on the road.
Kommen im Samstag ab 20 Uhr Open Air in Finofort auf dem Mühlenplatz Festgelände.
Mit den Fritz-DJs Frankie Mansell und Stefan Ritter. Die Fritz-90er-Party on the road. Die 90er feiern.
Und ich geh mit diesem Konzert an.
Ja, man könnte so viel noch erzählen. Und wir erzählen auch noch ein bisschen was. Zum Beispiel die Sache mit den Telefonnummern. Im Internet funktioniert das ja mit den Namensräumen ganz anders. Da gibt es diese Domains. Es gibt auch ein Schema, wie man die gute alte Welt der Telefonnummern auf die im Internet übliche Erfragung von Namen, in diesem Fall Telefonnummern, umstellt. Das Projekt heißt Enum, enum.org. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, welchen Status das hat, ob das schon irgendwie höhere Weinen hat. Ich habe nur gesehen, die DENIC hat es zumindest schon mal für 4, 9, hat sie schon mal diese Delegation bekommen.
Das ist durchaus ganz offiziell standardisiert.
Vielleicht kurz erklärt, wie es funktioniert, wenn man so ein Telefonnummer hat, von links nach rechts. Dann fängt die ja immer an mit Country Code, Area Code, das stirbt jetzt langsam ein bisschen aus, weil es eh Quatsch ist und dann halt eben die Teilnehmeranschlussnummer. Für Deutschland ist es halt am Anfang 4, 9, für andere Länder was anderes, sodass man eben schon mal in etwa weiß, wo geht das hin. Im Internet läuft das natürlich alles ein bisschen anders. Da kann irgendwie jede Nummer bedeuten, dass es wieder in ein ganz anderen Kontinent geht. Aber man hat jetzt einfach die Telefonnummer genommen und im Prinzip umgedreht, Punkte dazwischen gemacht, und dann ist das wie ein Domain-Name. Also wenn ich irgendwie www.fubar.org habe, dann wird halt erst org nachgeschlagen, dann wird fubar nachgeschlagen, dann wird www.fubar.org nachgeschlagen und dann kriege ich eben die gewünschte Informationen, wie zum Beispiel eine IP-Adresse von einem Webserver. Und bei Telefonnummern möchte man halt auch gerne herausfinden, was ist der für diese Rufnummer zuständige Telefonserver. Da habe ich jetzt also eine Rufnummer wie 4912345, dann wird das eben genauso umgedreht. Also ich habe 54321, 49, da mache ich da überall Punkte dazwischen, dann liest man das wie eine Domain, von hinten nach, also von rechts nach links, also quasi die 9 und dann die 4 und dann so weiter. Und 9 und 4, das ist dann eben für Deutschland, das liegt derzeit bei der DNIC und so richtig weiterverteilt wird das derzeit noch nicht. Also ich bin mir nicht so ganz im Bilde darum, wie es jetzt eigentlich real schon mit dieser Delegation, dieser Rufnummer aussieht und wer das jetzt eigentlich tun soll. Aber technisch funktioniert es im Prinzip genauso wie DNS. Und dann kommt man eben von Ziffer zu Ziffer bis eben zu der eigentlichen Rufnummer, die man anrufen will und dann kann man einfach eine DNS-Abfrage machen, bitte gib mir doch mal diesen Server. So funktioniert das im Prinzip. Weißt du, wie das ist, wer das vergibt oder so?
Kann ich jetzt auch nicht sagen im Detail, ich hab nur gerade noch mal nachgeguckt. Also angefangen hat das Ganze im Jahr 2000 mit der RFC2916, in der also spezifiziert ist, wie man diese Telefonnummern, wie wir sie kennen, die sogenannten E.164-Nummern, auf diese DNS-Namen ummappt. Und da hat sich wohl die ITU damit beschäftigt und auch wieder die ITF. Und da haben wir jetzt wieder diese zwei konkurrierenden Standardisierungsgremien. Und einen offiziellen Standard gibt es wohl nicht. Es gibt diese alte RFC, die das beschreibt. Das hat man dann noch verändert und abgewandelt. Und es gibt jetzt ein relativ neues Dokument vom, naja, März 2002, in dem so die historische Entwicklung dieses Enum-Standards dokumentiert wird. Aber so richtig tatsächlich irgendwo festgeschrieben ist das wohl offensichtlich noch nicht. Ja, gut, den Rest hat ja Tim schon erklärt.
Also das läuft. Es gibt einen Testbetrieb beim DENIC www.denic.de. Da müsste man das sehen. Soweit ich das sehen kann, kann man sich durchaus schon eine Telefonnummer sozusagen verservieren lassen.
Ja, aber den muss ja im Prinzip abgeglichen werden mit dem schon existierenden Rufnummernbereich.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, aber dann ist da wahrscheinlich die, wie heißt die tolle Behörde? Wir versuchen alles zu regeln, tp.tp, genau. Ja, was auch noch so zur internationalen Verständigung dazu gehört, das haben wir bisher noch nicht so richtig erwähnt, aber nicht ganz unwichtig, ist natürlich, dass man dasselbe Encoding verwendet für die Sprache. Und da gibt es sehr viele. Und offensichtlich ist das auch noch ein Schlachtfeld, wo dann auch wieder mal diese unseligen Patente mit reinschlagen. Also um nochmal kurz zu erklären, was ich meine, wenn ich jetzt ein Telefongespräch führe im normalen Telefonnetz, dann funktioniert das vor allem deshalb, weil mein Telefon die Sprache genauso einpackt, wie es das andere auf der Seite wieder auspackt. Also normale Codiererei nennt man PCM. Das ist einfach das, was alle verwendet haben, schon immer. Im Internet ist es ganz wichtig, dass man eben so viel Platz spart, wie möglich. Im Telefonnetz hat man sich halt einmal geeinigt, man macht irgendwie 8 Kilobit und das war's. Und das verwenden eben alle, aber schon im GSM-Netz, wo eben die Datenraten ganz...
Beim Telefonnetz geht es auch schon los.
Ja, im Prinzip habe ich erstmal, sage ich nichts Falsches. Mir geht es ja erstmal darum, zu verstehen, wo das herkommt, im Mobiltelefon.
64 Kilobit.
Bitte?
Was habe ich denn gesagt? Acht.
Ah, ähm, Entschuldigung. Achttausend Bytes, meinte ich natürlich. Bytes, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall im GSM, wo schon das alles über die Luft übertragen wird und wo die Bandbreiten sehr viel schmaler sind, hat man sich eben schon auf eine andere Enkoding-Standard festgelegt. Also in der GSM-Verschlüsselung. Wie heißt die? G711?
Verschlüsselung.
Entschuldigung, Enkoding. Ich bin schon ein bisschen müde.
Im Grunde gibt es das Problem, aber wenn ich das noch einwerfen darf, in der Telefonie auch schon, es gibt den ALoR und den MULoR-Standard für das Enkoding und die Amerikaner verwenden das eine, die Europäer das andere und das muss man dann immer schön umsetzen. Nur da merkt der Anwender eben nichts davon, weil das alles die Telefonunternehmen unter sich klären. Bei Internettelefonie gibt es keine Telefonunternehmen, zumindest nicht zwangsläufig. Und dann müssen eben die Programme oder die Telefone, die man verwendet, diese unterschiedlichen Standards untereinander aushandeln können und auch unterstützen.
Ja, aber es gibt da eine ganze Menge Player, die da irgendwie mit rumspielen. Ich weiß nicht, was jetzt Realverbreitung hat. Es gibt halt diese diversen G-Standards von der ITU. G711 ist glaube ich recht verbreitet.
Das ist Alo Mühler. G711 ist Alo Mühler. G729 ist glaube ich ein ADPCM, Adaptive Pulse Code Modulation. Aber ich kenne die G-Nummern leider überhaupt nicht ausländisch.
Es gibt wohl noch eine G723 und eine G728, die auch für die Verbreitung schieben.
Also üblicherweise muss ein Internettelefon auf jeden Fall schon verschiedene Codex können. Und im Rahmen dieser Kontaktaufnahme mit dem SEP-Protokoll, was wir schon mehrfach erwähnt haben, wird eben auch das unter anderem ausgehandelt.
Da gibt es also dann im Prinzip jedes Telefon weiß ja, was für Standards es unterstützt, was für Encodings. Und zum Verbindungsaufbau sagt dann jedes Telefon dem anderen, was es denn für Standards unterstützt. Und dann wird eben der gewählt, der nach welchen Kriterien auch immer als der Geschickte erscheint.
Ja, wobei man durchaus auch über eine alte Modemstrecke noch übers Internet telefonieren könnte. Wenn man ein GSM-Codec verwendet, dann ist man auf 6, 4 Kilobit, glaube ich, runter. Die Sprachqualität ist sehr schlecht. Das ist der alte Klang aus der Mülltonne, den man ganz früh, ganz früher hatte. Das Klang aus der Mülltonne, Oscar in der Mülltonne.
Ja, richtig, also man kann auch mit einem 33, 6er oder noch langsameren Modem, Internetanwindung und einem entsprechenden Codec wie dem GSM-Codec noch übers Internet telefonieren. Man muss da kein DSL haben.
Also ich habe das gerade mal ausprobiert, als ich irgendwie in Tschechien in der Pampa saß, mit meinem SIP-Telefon, das war nicht so...
Es ist nicht prickelnd, aber es geht.
Ja, aber da kamen wahrscheinlich noch diverse Fehlerkorrekturen.
Die Latency ist halt noch das Problem bei den Modems, weil die analogen Modems eine sehr viel höhere Latenzzeit haben als irgendwelche digitalen Verfahren wie ISDN oder DSL. Und da merkt man die Verzögerung dann schon deutlich schlechter, aber es geht.
GSM arbeitet auch mit großen Blockgrößen, dann ist man dann leicht bei einer Sekunde, das ist dann so, wie wenn man früher über Satellit in Amerika angerufen hat und zwei Sekunden später seine eigene Stimme als Echo gehört hat.
Das hört man nur, wenn du so einen Ü-Wagen über Inmarsat verbindest, da hast du das genauso.
Ja genau, genau. Das ist dann auch kein Spaß mehr. Das hat dann auch mit Telefonieren auch nichts mehr zu tun. Das ist wirklich mehr so CB-Funk. Einer spricht, der andere hört zu, unterbrechen wird schwierig. Die ganzen sozialen Bedingungen des Telefonierens ändern sich dann doch sehr stark. Aber das ist, wir haben ja jetzt heute telefoniert, nicht so, war überhaupt kein Problem.
Ja, das Internet ist einfach zu gut. Man hat viel zu viel investiert, wo man noch viel Geld hatte und jetzt liegen die Kapazitäten brach.
Was für ein Satz.
Ja, gut. Da steht Triphop.
Bei dem steht nicht Triphop.
Nur bei den anderen steht Triphop.
Das ist das einzige, wo nicht Triphop steht.
Ich tue was, was man nicht tun darf.
Tripp steht natürlich für Telephony Routing over IP.
Wir hatten Zipgate vor allen Dingen ausführlich bearbeitet. Mit dir telefoniere ich gerne über iChat.
Ja, Apple hat das ja recht prominent in seine Instant Messaging Applikation, eben dieses iChat eingebaut. Und zwar dann eben auch nicht nur für Audio Telefonie, sondern auch gleich für Bild Telefonie. Das funktioniert auch bemerkenswert gut. Der Unterschied ist, sie benutzen, soweit ich weiß, auch Zip. Allerdings sind sie halt eingebunden in dieses Instant Messaging System. Sprich, man wählt halt keine Telefonnummern, sondern man findet eben seinen Gegenüber, so wie man eben das für das Austauschen von Textnachrichten auch schon tut, nämlich einfach in der eigenen Buddyliste oder eben durch diesen Namen. Sprich, das Telefonbuch ist der Instant Messaging Dienst selber. Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch, auch wenn ich jetzt leider eben nicht irgendeine Telefonnummer eingeben kann und dann da auch anrufen kann. Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn dieses Feature bald kommt, aber geben tut es das auf jeden Fall noch nicht.
In der Windows-Welt gibt es ja zum Beispiel den Microsoft Messenger, der eben auch auf dem SIP-Protokoll basiert und eben auch sowohl Telefonie als auch Bildübertragung unterstützt. Das ist auch vielleicht ein wichtiger Punkt, den man an der Stelle erwähnen muss, dass diese Protokolle oder na insbesondere das SIP nicht nur an Audiodaten gebunden sind, sondern ich kann da eben auch Video damit übertragen oder auch Textdateien, was auch immer. Also es ist grundsätzlich möglich, unterschiedliche Inhalte zu vermitteln über diese Protokolle. Es gibt auch Leute, die so verwerst sind und zum Beispiel Fax über H323 machen. Das ist dann wohl die Krönung.
Darüber schweigen wir. Ich würde ganz gern nochmal kurz, wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit, über die Gefahren eigentlich reden und jetzt im Sinne von Katastrophensicherheit, Notrufe über SIP, diese Sachen, das ist vielleicht auch interessant.
Ja, das ist wohl sicherlich ein großes Problem. So ein analoges Telefon ist schön einfach. Da kommt die Versorgungsspannung über die Telefonleitung mit. Man braucht da keinen Strom dazu. Es kann also der Strom ausfallen und mein analoges Telefon geht immer noch. Auch das, was da gesprochen wird, ist elektrisch sehr einfach. Mit ganz primitiven Equipment kann man da eben telefonieren. Bei ESDN wird das schon komplizierter. Für ein einzelnes ESDN-Telefon kriege ich den Strom auch noch über meine ESDN-Leitung mit drüber. Wenn ich jetzt aber eine Telefonanlage betreibe, dann habe ich schon das Problem in der aller Regel, dass sobald der Strom weg ist, kann ich nicht mehr telefonieren, kann ich keinen Notruf mehr absetzen.
Kann man sich nicht so ein Netzteil löten, was aus der ESDN-Leitung genug Strom für alles nimmt eigentlich? Das ist eine sehr romantische Vorstellung.
Das ist nicht sehr belastbar, was da anliegt. Wenn du mehrere Telefone an einen ESDN-Anschluss anschließt, dann kannst du die schon alle auch so umstellen, dass die Strom über aus dem ESDN rauskommen. Aber das funktioniert dann nicht mehr zuverlässig.
Wenn man eine Telefonanlage hat, wie das vorhin auch schon in einer netten Konferenz vorgeschlagen wurde, man macht so seinen Router gleichzeitig zur Telefonanlage, überhaupt zu diesem Gerät, wo alles aufschlägt, und wenn man dann noch eine UPS einbaut und eben auch...
Also UPS vielleicht erklären?
Ja, also eine unterbrechungsfreie Stromversorgung, USV auf Deutsch, Uninterruptible Power Supply auf Englisch. Also wenn man das Ding sozusagen von der Stromversorgung des Hausnetzes löst und die Möglichkeit bietet, zumindest ein paar Stunden zu überleben, wenn irgendwas ganz garstig ist, dann könnte man weiter denken, Power over Ethernet zu machen für die Telefone, zum Leihstift, dass die halt auch dann aus diesem Stromfondus versorgt werden. Das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, aber sicherlich nicht...
Und teuer auch.
Wer stellt sich schon eine unterbrechungsfreie Stromversorgung daheim hin, nur dass er im Notfall mal telefonieren kann?
Ja gut, aber dann hast du immer noch das Problem, wenn der Strom wirklich im Haus ausfällt, ist es auch recht wahrscheinlich, dass dann auch dein DSL schon gar nicht mehr geht.
Richtig.
Also das ist alles ziemlich haarig so. Ein Vorteil von analogem Telefon, es ist einfach so simpel, dass es gut ist. Ich würde sogar fast empfehlen, egal wie viel ihr macht, eine analoge Telefonleitung solltet ihr euch sozusagen noch übrigen, damit ihr zu noten Elektriker noch anrufen könnt.
Oder nur denn dran klemmen oder so.
Ja, Notrufe, das geht ja noch weiter. Selbst wenn alles funktioniert, rufe ich 110 an. Wenn ich jetzt...
Hast du das mal probiert mit dem Telefon?
Natürlich habe ich das nicht probiert, weil ich weiß, was da passiert.
Üblicherweise möchte man ja, wenn man jetzt 110 anruft, dann möchte man ja üblicherweise mit der Polizei verbunden werden in der Stadt oder dem Landkreis, in dem man gerade lebt.
Ja, aber mein Gott, da lasse ich mir von irgendwie, nehme ich mir ein altes Mobiltelefon, sehe zu, dass der Akku geladen ist und lege das daneben im Zweifel. Also wenn ich unbedingt einen Notruf haben will.
Um nicht zur Volksverdummung beizutragen, der Notruf ist 112.
Nur ums Mar gesagt zu haben.
Was dachtest du?
Mit allgemein.
Die meisten Leute glauben, es ist 110.
Na, das ist die Polizei.
Ja, aber trotzdem. Geh mal auf die Straße, ich habe das mal gemacht, ich frage mal die Leute, was der Notruf ist, und sie sagen 110.
Das kommt vom vielen RTL 2 Kumpel.
Nee, das war auch schon vorher so. Keine Ahnung, es steckt irgendwie so drin. So um die erste Zahl. Die Volksverdummung haben wir jetzt gestoppt. Sie breitet sich nicht weiter aus.
Das Problem, wie gesagt, die Zustellung eines Notrufs, egal über welche Nummer der jetzt geht, an die entsprechende Notruf stelle, die dann auch tatsächlich physisch in der Nähe ist. Das ist natürlich etwas, was überhaupt nicht lösbar ist im Prinzip.
Der amerikanische Senat hat beschlossen, dass sie das unbedingt gerne wollen. Aber wie das nun technisch gemacht werden soll, ist noch absolut schleierhaft. Weil im Internet man einfach die geografische Zuordnung nicht mehr so ohne weiteres hat. Deine Telefongesellschaft sieht sozusagen das andere Ende des Kabels und weiß, wo du bist.
Richtig, das habe ich beim Internet nicht mehr. Man könnte jetzt sagen, gut, zumindest das Land könnte man vielleicht noch herausfinden, indem man einfach über diese Internet-Registries guckt, wo denn die IP-Adresse zu gewesen ist. Bringt einem aber auch nichts, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen VPN-Tunnel habe. Also ich bin gerade in den USA, habe eine VPN-Verbindung nach Deutschland und habe dann eine deutsche IP-Adresse. Es funktioniert einfach nicht, da gibt es keine Lösung.
Also in Düsseldorf mit Zipgate funktioniert es in Düsseldorf tatsächlich mit der 110 die lokale Polizei anzurufen.
Macht man das nicht immer mit 110?
Na Moment, da hat man dann...
Aber nicht die Düsseldorfer Polizei. Also wenn du in Düsseldorf bist, kannst du mit 110 in Düsseldorf die Polizei anrufen.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass du dir eine Düsseldorfer Rufnummer zuweisen hast, Lasse. Aber wenn ich jetzt in Berlin sitze und mir eine 0911 Nürnberger Vorwahl geben habe, Lasse, und ich rufe 110 an, dann traue ich mich wetten, dass ich in Nürnberg gerade auf Polizei rauskomme.
Da wollte ich auch mein Geld drauf verwetten.
Ja, ich auch. Aber wir haben ja Gott sei Dank keins mehr.
Ein anderes Problem, das es auch noch gibt, ist überhaupt, dass Telefonnummern nicht mehr an Orte gebunden sind.
Ich habe es gerade auf der Zipgate-Seite gefunden. Du kannst in deinem Profil sagen, was passieren soll, wenn du 110 wählst, also welche Polizei.
Das heißt, dass Zipgate diese Vorsichtsmaßnahme schon getroffen hat. Das ist ziemlich verantwortlich.
Obwohl du gerade meinst, mit diesen Area-Quotes, das bricht halt alles auf. Also in Deutschland ist es ja im Prinzip noch so, man denkt halt immer, der Heimanschluss hatte halt, ich bin in Berlin, ich bin 030. Das funktioniert ja schon nicht mehr mit irgendwie hier O2, mit dem Genion-Dienst und so. Das weicht ja alles auf. Man kann jetzt auch eine U-Nummer ja beliebig übernehmen. Also irgendwann greift das eh nicht mehr. In Tschechien ist es zum Beispiel so, dass dort Area-Quotes komplett abgeschafft wurden. Also die haben einfach ein komplett neues Numbering-System eingefüllt vor ein, zwei, drei Jahren. Und jetzt haben sie halt einfach Nummernblöcke und fertig. Da ist überhaupt nichts mehr codiert mit irgendeinem Ort. Echt modern.
Das große Problem, was man dabei eben hat, insbesondere jetzt noch in Deutschland, wo doch häufig die Tarifierung doch noch unterschiedlich ist, ob mal ein Ortsnetzgespräch führt oder eben ein Ferngespräch. In vielen anderen Ländern ist das eigentlich völlig irrelevant. Und dann ist mir eigentlich auch egal, was das für eine Vorwahl hat. Nur in Deutschland hat man eben immer noch so diesen Gedanken im Hinterkopf, wenn das jetzt die gleiche Vorwahl hat wie meine, dann ist es günstiger oder so. Da müsste halt auch die Tarifierung sich dann ändern, weil sonst man überhaupt nicht mehr herausfinden kann, wie viel man denn zahlt jetzt.
Das ist auch wirklich albern.
Ja, aber es wird so bleiben.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, dass es so bleiben wird. Also bei der Telekom wird es sicherlich noch ein bisschen so bleiben, aber bei den anderen Providern, denen ist es eigentlich schon so, weil es auch keinen Unterschied macht.
Es gibt schon AQUA-Tarife zum Beispiel, die überhaupt keinen Unterschied mehr machen. Zwischen OZ-Gespräche, das ist halt deutschlandweit so und so viel Cent pro Minute.
Weil es macht für die auch überhaupt keinen Unterschied mehr. Der Treffig verteilt sich eh gleichmäßig und das ist Quark.
Kommen wir zum Ende, meine Herren?
Ja, wir haben sicherlich das ein oder andere unerwähnt gelassen. Das, was wir nicht gesagt haben, das könnt ihr beitragen. Zum Beispiel in unserer Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia, die wir mal einrichten. Die Adresse dazu findet ihr bei ChaosradioCCCDE. Da klickt ihr dann ruf und dann könnt ihr alles reinschreiben, was ihr noch an nützlichen Links, Tipps, Kommentaren, Anmerkungen, Verbesserungen oder Besserwissereien so aufbieten könnt. Das wollen wir auch künftig so halten. Thema für die nächste Sendung haben wir noch nicht. Da müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen drüber nachgrübeln. Da sind wir natürlich auch an Feedback interessiert. Da auch ist in diesem Fall diese Wikipedia-Seite ganz hilfreich. Da könnt ihr eure Vorschläge eintragen, wenn ihr der Meinung seid, darüber müssten wir schon immer mal schnacken. Wir machen das halt immer sehr kurzfristig und deswegen sind wir dann auch mal halbwegs aktuell. Binden wir uns ein.
Binden wir uns ein. Das war das Chaosradio Nr. 94. Nr. 95 am letzten Montag im August.
Ich geh schon mal.
Mittwoch natürlich.
Nein, nein, nein, es ist nicht so. Es ist verschoben. Auf den ersten Mittwoch im September. Es ist der erste. Aus Termingründen, ja.
Verstehe.
Deswegen ist diesmal alles anders als die Regel.
Warum weiß ich davon nichts?
Weiß ich nicht. Hast du mir das nicht gemailt?
Nein. Dann war Max dran. Das war's wahrscheinlich Max, weil ich an der nächsten Sendung ja gar nicht da ist ja dann Max wieder dran. Genau.
Es gibt da irgendeinen Vorfall und irgendeine Priorität, den wir uns da unterzuordnen haben. Und wir neigen unsere Körpfe und sagen, dann machen wir es halt am 1. September.
Chaosradio hat natürlich eine niedrige Priorität. Das ist ja klar.
Ja, so ist das. Vielen Dank, Harald. Vielen Dank, Lars. Vielen Dank, Tim.
Vielen Dank, Holger.
Und gute Nacht noch. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen ab 1 Uhr. Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf.
Tschüss.
Was noch?
Ja, Holger, ist deine letzte Chaosradio Sendung mit uns, oder? Das ist schade.
Endlich keine dummen Fragen mehr. Endlich frei. Keine Tours mehr.
Ja, aber du hast uns ja ein paar Jahre begleitet. Das fand ich auch sehr gut. Dann sagen wir auch Dankeschön für.